Oh, zu leise, Musik ist zu laut.
Jetzt passt's.
So, ich hab euch schon mal aufgemalt, was wir heute ungefähr machen oder was wir heute
nachbauen.
Versteht kein Mensch, ich selber nicht mal mehr, aber, die gucken wir mal.
Und ich hab, dass ihr euch das besser vorstellen könnt, schon mal, schon mal was zum Testen
gebaut.
Oh, WTF, ich hab auch noch Skype auf, auf dem zweiten Rechner seh ich grad.
Das verbindet sich nicht mehr, weil die Version zu alt ist.
Aber warum hab ich da überhaupt noch Skype drauf installiert, Alter?
Weirdchamp, Weirdchamp, richtig krasser, Hardcore Weirdchamp.
Ach, hab ich heute Geburtstag?
Wusst ich noch gar nicht.
Aber exzellent, ich würd sagen, das ist doch ein Subwert.
Komm mal, Sub sind so billig jetzt.
Statt 5 Euro nur noch 4 Euro, da kann man es sich ja eigentlich mal gönnen.
Außerdem gibt's Poggers Emotes, zum Beispiel unter anderem sowas Tolles wie Wubbetge.
Ich weiß nicht, wie du drauf kommst, dass ich heute Geburtstag hab, aber nein, ich hab
keinen Geburtstag.
No Pass.
Oh, ich muss noch mal schnell in meine Mails gucken.
Zack, das hab ich noch gar nicht gemacht, also in meine privaten.
So, zeig mal her, gibt's irgendwas?
Ihr DHL-Paket kommt bald, wo möchten sie es empfangen?
Gute Nachrichten, ihr DHL-Paket ist fast da.
Voraussichtlich, ah, das ist die Fräse, die Rohrhochdruckreiniger Fräse.
Heute kein Hetzerstelz, nee, aber ähnlicher Big Brain Kram, der Rohrreiniger, die Rohrreiniger
Fräse, genau.
Äh, sonst hat keiner was geschenkt.
Die sind ja geil, lull.
Ich hab grad ne Werbeanfrage bekommen, ob ich, ob ich, ob ich was vorstellen will und
genau den hab ich vor nem, vor, ich wollt sagen, am halben Jahr, aber ist noch kein
halbes Jahr her, vor, hab ich nicht zwei Monaten oder so geantwortet, hab ich ihm gesagt, was
ich mir preislich vorstelle und dann meinten sie, ah nee, das ist uns zu teuer, sie wollen
ihn plus 200 Euro bezahlen oder so und jetzt, jetzt fragen sie wieder an, wird mich
freuen, wenn wir das irgendwie hinbekommen können, ja es ist ganz einfach, wie wir das
hinbekommen.
Wenn ihr ordentlich was bezahlt, dann mach ich das auch, aber ich preis doch nicht irgendwie,
irgendwelche random Dinger an für, für ein Appel und ein Ei.
Aus dem Weg geringen Verdiener, nein, nein, so war das nicht gemein, Leute, aber, ähm,
man darf das nicht unter Wert machen.
Du kannst mir den gewünschten Preis mitteilen, ja hab ich doch schon, hab ich doch schon,
und das wolltet ihr nicht, das letzte war, so, ähm, Stream bis Bettke, das kann durchaus
sein, dass wir heute bis Bettke unterwegs sind, durchaus, durchaus, ich muss mal kurz
diesen ganzen, ganzen Crap hier zu machen, was hab ich denn hier noch auf?
Ach, Moment, mein DHL-Paket kommt, kommen vielleicht schon die Hausnummern, wait a minute, kommen
schon die Hausnummern vielleicht, Moment, Moment, ich muss mal, ich muss mal Absender
gucken, ich muss mal Absender gucken, Absender DHL-Paket, ihr, wo war das denn jetzt, ihr
DHL-Paket kommt halt, Absender ist, nee, Däuber GmbH und KOKG, nee, das klingt nicht nach
Ali, AliExpress Hausnummern, nee, wann gibt's denn wieder mal die Home-Tour, es gab noch
nie eine komplett zusammengehängende Home-Tour, es gab immer die Baustelle, nee, es sind
nicht die Hausnummern, okay, man, die ganzen, ganzen, die da sind das, aber, ja, das Ding
hab ich bestellt, also erstmal, ich muss mal kurz den ganzen Cramp hier zu machen, den
ich hier, die letzten Streams über geöffnet, so, das brauchen wir noch, excellent, oh,
okay, ab, gehen wir fort, gibt's eins ab, excellent, excellent, huge subscription hier, biggest
playtime, wann's mit dem Overlay-Cham weitergeht, ja, das weiß ich noch nicht so genau, also
wir müssen Hetzner Stream machen mit Kontainerisierung von unserer KekW-Assessor, KekW, bitte schön,
ja, Anwendung, dann müssen wir Overlay-Cham weitermachen, und ich darf auch andere sagen,
es gibt, gibt viele Sachen, die wir machen müssen, mal gucken, wann das, wann das kommt,
General Slay, Dankeschön für den Sub, ich muss mal schnell reingucken, ich hab bestimmt
wieder jede Menge Sachen vergessen, so, das machen wir heute, zumindest ansatzweise, und
ich zeig euch jetzt auch gleich mal, dass es funktioniert, ups, ähm, der Skillkiller
hat noch Subscribed, zwar aber gestern schon, trotzdem, danke, falls da bist, für den Sub,
massive subscriptions hier wieder, KekW, genau, ich versteh bis heute nicht, warum, die Amis
sind aber eh nicht normal, was das angeht, warum heißt, wobei, das ist ja, das ist ja
nicht mal die Amis, das sind englische Sachen, ähm, W, ich weiß, warum, das, aber, aber
der, alles andere ist schön kurz auszusprechen, aber W, alter, das ist so wie Y bei uns oder
sowas, auch total, viel, viel unnötig lang, mein Desktop ist poggans, ich weiß gar nicht,
was, chat, weirdchamp, weirdchamp, wer was gegen diesen Desktop hat, huge weirdchamp,
kann ich überhaupt nicht verstehen, um nicht zu sagen, nicht nur weirdchamp, sondern auch
noch weirdchamping, also gegen diesen Desktop kann man eigentlich gar nichts haben, oder
ich kann zumindest nicht verstehen, wie man gegen diesen Desktop was haben kann, bester
Hintergrund, ja, seh ich auch so, so, ich zeig euch jetzt mal, ich hab, ich hab, ich hab
was vorbereitet, chat, mal kurz die Musik ein bisschen leiser machen, die ist ein bisschen
laut, exquisite Musik hier, sag mal, hat, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das,
es hat irgendwas an meinem Noisegate rumgestellt, kann das sein, beziehungsweise generell hier
an dem, Moment, wo ist mein Kompressor hin, ich hab doch da immer ein Kompressor noch
drin, wo ist der denn hin, hä, keck, keck, triple weight, egal, will ich, passt jetzt
nicht an, ah, Sneaky Boy, danke schön für den Zap, ich zeig euch mal was, ich hab, ich
hab schon was, ich hab schon was zum simulieren vorbereitet, dass ihr euch das besser vorstellen
könnt, und dann erklär ich mal, erklär ich mal was zu, ähm, wo ist denn das hier, Rider,
Rider Projects, Klingelchamp ist am Start, äh, ich mach den Klingelchamp erstmal in
Virtual Studio auf, dass man, dass man das besser, dass man das besser erkennt, also,
der Mavcraft, hört sich auch falsch an irgendwie, so, dann, dann erklär ich, erklär ich das
mal, ich beweise euch auch jetzt, dass es, dass es funktioniert, ich beweise, ich beweise
euch jetzt auch, dass es funktioniert, also, ich starte jetzt mal, jaja, Passwort liegt,
ich weiß, ich weiß, ähm, ich beweise euch jetzt mal, dass es funktioniert, also, ich
hab da sowas, dass der Chat sich das besser vorstellen kann, was wir heute machen, hab
ich das, hab ich das mal so simuliert, simuliert, ja, also, wenn man das jetzt, wenn man das
jetzt startet, dann gibt es eine Fake Klingel, dass man sich das besser, dass man sich das
ganze besser vorstellen kann, ok, also, und ich zeig euch, ich zeig euch auch, dass es
funktioniert, nein, nein, wir machen jetzt kein Update, ich zeig euch jetzt auch, dass
es funktioniert, also, was wir machen, ich erklär das mal, also, Sinn und Zweck der
ganzen Übung, hier, da ist der A plus E Graf, ist da, so, also, der Ziel der ganzen Übung
ist folgendes, ich hab eine Kamera an der Hoftür, nicht die, so eine Tür, das ist nicht
meine Gegensprechanlage, die sieht nicht so aus, ähm, so, ich hab eine Kamera am Hoftor
und ich hab eine Tür Gegensprechanlage, die ich an der Fritzbox angeschlossen hab, so,
überdeckt, was ich jetzt machen will ist, ich will, dass es an der Tür klingelt und
dass es dann einen Anruf gibt an die Fritzbox, dass die Fritzbox diesen Anruf weiterleitet
an mein eigenes Programm, was wir heute basteln, äh, ich bin mir mit der Musiklautstärke
sicher, so, an mein eigenes Programm weiterleitet, dieses Programm nimmt den Call von der Tür
an, ruft sich parallel den Kamerafeed ab und baut aus Telefonanruf von der Tür klingelt
und dem Kamerabild einen weiteren Call zusammen, den es an jeden x-beliebigen SIP-Klien schicken
kann, das bedeutet, wir wollen quasi das Audio von der Tür mit der Kamera, mit der Raspberry
Pi Kamera verbinden und daraus quasi dann einen kombinierten Anruf machen, so, die
Sprache sagt mir nix, das haben wir vor, so, und ich hab jetzt mal so zum simulieren für
den Chat, dass ihr das nachvollziehen könnt, mal was gebastelt, dass man auch sieht, dass
es funktioniert, dass ich nicht jedes Mal runtergehen muss, ja, zurück Audio auch, selbstverständlich
auch zurück Audio, Audio in beide Richtungen natürlich, ja, jaja, das muss ich vielleicht
noch hier drauf malen, das ist noch verkehrt, wir wollen nicht nur das dahin, sondern wir
wollen auch noch, wollen wir blau, so, wir wollen natürlich auch noch Audio, aber nicht
Video zurück, sondern nur Audio zurück, so, und das Audio muss dann natürlich auch hier
von der Fritzbox wieder zurück an die Tür, dass der Dude was hört, so, geht es zu Mr.
N oder, es geht um Mr. N, das weißt du, das hab ich ja gesagt, hab ich ja gesagt, also
zu Mr. T, zu Mr. T mach ich dir im nächsten Video, von wegen wir versuchen illegale Sachen
auf der Arbeit zu hausten, muss ich aber besonders anonym machen, hast du eine Siedleklingel,
ich hab ne Siedleklingel, aber nicht, die sieht ähnlich aus dazu, ja, aber das hat
fast jeder irgendwie ne Siedleklingel, der Eis verkauft, da hab ich ja schon gar nicht
mehr dran gedacht, wusste gar nicht, dass du mich subscribt hast, nice, tschüss, ähm,
wusste ich gar nicht, dass du hier auch am Start bist, äh, wie hast du die Türsprechstelle
an die Fritzbox angeboten, mit dem Siedler Gateway, korrekt, korrekt, hier ist in Wirklichkeit
noch, hier ist in Wirklichkeit noch, das ist nämlich gar kein Deck, das ist gar kein
Decktelefon hier an der Tür, das ist eigentlich nur ne Türklingel, Tür, ah, oh hier Klingel,
Klingel, huge pain skills, und dann ist in Wirklichkeit, ist hier dazwischen, ist noch
nen Decktelefon, Decktelefon, ja, so siehts in Wirklichkeit aus, ja, das hab ich so gar
nicht, hab ich gar nicht realisiert, dass du das bist, lustig, ja, gut, wir dürfen
jetzt nix liegen hier also wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben hast du mal dein siedler zeugs mit dem
gateway irgendwo verlinkt also als gateway benutze ich das ding das ist offiziell von siedler und ist
schweine was sind das heute bei google und ist schweine teuer neu wird man sich aber auch nie
neu kaufen ich mein guckt euch das mal an wer gibt dafür geld wer gibt da so ein geld für aus
deswegen geht mehr einfach auf ebay und kauft sich das ganze für 100 euro gebraucht juckt ja
nicht halbe grafikkarte genau also ok so jetzt habe ich jetzt habe ich ja ungefähr ungefähr
versucht zu gehen und ich beweise euch jetzt mal dass es prinzipiell funktioniert also also
bescheuerte aussage also das hier funktioniert noch gar nichts das programmieren wir heute aber
dass mein simulator funktioniert zeige ich euch jetzt mal und zwar das sieht nicht nur aus wie
eine türklingel die kann auch telefonieren also dieser weg hier also das hier dieser teil
funktioniert jetzt schon mit dem simulator ich zeige euch das mal guckt mal hört mal hier ich
habe hier mein fritz phone glaubt ihr es mir ich drücke da gerade wie verrückt drauf so ich habe
ich habe hier mein fritz phone so und wenn ich jetzt hier drauf klicke max a ja ja dann müssen
wir mal zugucken was er macht der simuliert übrigens auch die zwei sekunden delay also
also noch mal noch mal zum beweis noch mal noch mal zum beweis hier also call und jetzt
achtung fritz phone ok dass das funktioniert also mein simulator tut schon mal das ist jetzt
ersatz für wie ihr hört nichts natürlich hört ihr was echt war das so leise ist doch
ppega fg baited mich jetzt natürlich hört man da was los tatsächlich man hört nichts
what the fuck warum hört man nichts es bimmelt im hintergrund mein wtf warum ich ich hörs ich
hörs genau also noch mal noch mal das ist noise canceling das ist das noise canceling the fuck
ich sag euch das ist das noise canceling ich mache ich mache jetzt mal kurz diesen ganzen krempel hier aus
so wartet mal wartet mal so jetzt aber jetzt aber jetzt jetzt muss man gleich was hören
achtung achtung jetzt jetzt hat man es gehört gut lull dann scheißen wir wieder ein uralt
klingelton das ist ein extra klingelton den ich extra dafür eingestellt habe dass wenn die
türklingel klingelt ich habe einen normalen klingelton und ich habe extra so einen uralten
klingelton von der türklingel rausgesucht dass ich es anhört für die türklingel wenn das
telefon klingelt wenn die tür anruft so also so diesen teil habe ich jetzt schon nachgebaut
also das ist das ist halt noch überhaupt nicht das was ich jetzt eigentlich machen will das ist
nur der ersatz für ich muss runtergehen zur tür und die tür macht einen deckt anruf und der
raspberry pi erkennt daran jetzt erkennt auch noch dass es klingelt das habe ich damit nachgebaut
sonst nichts und dass ich der chat das besser vorstellen kann also was wir jetzt mal probieren
ist also was heißt probieren ich weiß ja prinzipiell wie es geht weil ich es im vorfeld
schon mal ausprobiert habe ich fake jetzt gar nicht irgendwie als würde ich das nicht wissen
und sagt wie geht das denn hoch ist sie da es funktioniert ne ne also ich sag heute mal
wirklich ich weiß schon prinzipiell was man machen muss ich habe das im vorfeld schon ausprobiert
aber es ist nicht so nicht nicht so klar wie man wie man denkt wie sich das andere wenn die tür
anruft ja wie wird es es denn sonst nennen die tür klingelt dann geht es zu einem also von der
tür moment moment moment also twitter twitter ich habe doch hier ich habe doch hier den aufbau
auf twitter mal gepostet also guckt euch das mal so na twitter was soll was soll dieses gegängele
eigentlich es geht mir bei reddit schon auf den keks dass reddit mittlerweile nicht mehr richtig
aufgehen ohne login und ab und jetzt jetzt fängt twitter mit dem müll auch an so hier da war der
test was soll das gegängele twitter meine güte so hier war der testaufbau mittlerweile ist alles
im keller also das komplette ist jetzt im keller und das war halt dass es ans telefon dran passt
also wie das mit dem klingeln funktioniert ist relativ relativ simpel es sieht ja bloß nicht
so simpel aus also das sind die zwei adern von der tür gegensprechanlage weil sie nennt sich das
ganze 1 und 7 weil weil die ganzen tür gegensprechanlagen typen hersteller absolut
big brain technologie verwenden die sie immer selbst benennen wie es ihnen lustig ist und das
zeug heißt immer dass im prinzip ist das im prinzip ist 1 ground und 7 ist quasi dort wo alles
alles drüber geht 7 minus 1 gachi pass genau genau daran haben die bei siedler bestimmt gedacht
bei der benahmung die haben sich gedacht 1970 oder so wann die sich das ausgedacht haben haben
die sich gedacht 7 minus 1 gleich hyper gachi genau das haben die garantiert garantiert damit
sich das gedacht was sonst ist ob wir es total naheliegend dass die sich das gedacht haben
der chat wieder wirtschämt hier wirtschämt ich glaube es nicht so also mal kurz zur erklärung
wie das wie das angeschlossen also wie dieser part den ich jetzt simuliere hier vor allen
wirklichkeiten echt funktioniert also siedler diese ding besteht im prinzip nur aus zwei adern
ich habe übrigens glück dass ich nicht die allerneueste geschichte habe die allerneueste
geschichte bei siedler ist mit bus technologie das funktioniert nicht mehr so einfach also die
zwei adern von von der von der gegensprechanlage an diesen dc a 612 angeschlossen was das ding
macht ist das wand das das macht daraus einen analogen telefonanruf da kann man eine telefonnummer
einprogrammieren die es anrufen soll und dann geht das über den analogen port raus also das
ding macht quasi telefon klingel stimmt gar nicht türklingel gegensprechanlage zu analogen
telefonanruf das geht dann über das analoge kabel hier runter als was analoge kabel über
so ein standard telefon kabel hier runter in so eine extra box und die box macht daraus
im deckt call also sprich das hier ist quasi analog telefon zu deckt und die box ist selbst
an der fritzbox angemeldet also sprich es klingelt das ding erkennt aha es klingelt
macht daraus ein telefonanruf der telefonanruf geht hier runter und wird da per deckt an die
fritzbox geschickt und das hier ist im prinzip nur die stromversorgung das hier ist die stromversorgung
für dieses siedle ding weil die haben irgendwie waren der meinung wir machen nicht das wie
alle anderen nein wir brauchen 14,8 volt ac stromversorgung nicht wie jeder andere 5 bis
12 volt dc nein 14,8 volt was heißt das wechsel wechselspannung gibt es eigentlich videos von
einer katze klar da gibt es videos von einer katze guckt mal her hier habe ich das video
genannt hier da chico am start da ist er wenn ihr die katze sehen wollt das kann ich das
kann ich jederzeit können wir einrichten ja und wer sich übrigens wer sich fragt wer
sich fragt ihr habt ja teilweise schon in den streams gesehen wo wir was zusammen gebastelt
hatten du hattest doch eine kamera mit dem raspberry pi 0 ja genau diese kamera nehmen
wir dafür heute das hier die kamera in diesem bild ist eigentlich in raspberry pi 0 plus
pi cam ist das hier eigentlich so und wer sich fragt warum meine arme immer so aussehen
wie sie aussehen so sieht so sieht sie aus wenn sie entspannt ist ja da ist das alles
kein problem so aber manchmal überkommt es chico und deswegen sehen meine arme manchmal
so aus wie sie aussehen passt mal auf gefährliches tier also die kann mir da schon mal in armen
beißen und in armen in armen kratzen so wenn was ich mein ich legs jetzt ja auch drauf
an ich legs jetzt ja auch gerade drauf an
one on one one on one rast mit der katze genau jetzt lass mich die ruhe alle es geht nicht
um den tür öffner tür öffner macht das ding gar nicht wobei vielleicht macht das
auch tür öffner jetzt hat sie irgendwas gesehen rennt gleich weg zieler fast ja zieler
fast ja das ist die andere das ist die andere das ist das ist meine erste die ich hier
in dem haus hatte das ist original katz fps das ist original katz fps die hat immer so
grimmig geguckt so und das war die dicke hier guck mal das war meine dicke die hatte
die hatten richtig dicke die war richtig pippo fett ja und die hieß übrigens barbie die
dickste von allen hieß barbie aber die habe ich nicht so genannt das war die hieß die
hieß schon so also die dickste also bei der ersten hätte ich ja verstanden aber die hat
immer gerne fernsehe geguckt obwohl die raus durfte die hat immer gerne fernsehe geguckt
eichhörnchen und vögel und fische und sowas richtiger chunker ist das gewesen ja nee nee
fernseh runter runter geschmissen hat sie nicht guck mal geb her hol mal eins da so eigentlich
wollte ich jetzt gar nicht gar nicht katze mit euch gucken aber das mag die die hat die
hat sie unglaublich gerne eichhörnchen im fernseh angeguckt hast du die beiden andere
noch nee habe ich nicht die leben nicht mehr ich hatte die nie parallel alle ich hatte die
nur nacheinander die erste war ziemlich alt war schon 15 oder so und war krank die zweite
die habe ich aus dem tierheim geholt und die war auch schon krank als ich sie gekriegt
habe die hatte ich bloß in dreiviertel jahr oder so ja und schicko schicko habe ich jetzt schon
eine weile schicko habe ich jetzt glaube schon zweieinhalb jahre oder so so aber genug katz
geguckt alles klar mal kurz chat wie ist denn die qualität von der raspberry pi cam mit dem
passiv die ist in ordnung aber du musst darauf achten gerade schlechte beleuchtung ist halt
der killer also die bildqualität ist in ordnung auch auch sagen wir mal in 720p 1080p auch
mit 10 15 fps ist durchaus oder man kann es glaube ich man kann es glaube ich sogar bis
60 fps machen aber dann rauscht das geht das ist auch in ordnung die qualität aber sobald
es dunkel wird musst du die fps runter stellen und die belichtungszeit hoch stellen sonst
sieht es kacke aus ich habe die ich habe meine raspberry cam so eingestellt dass die bei nacht
mit einem fps läuft mit einem fps habe ich genug licht von der laterne dass das bild relativ
hell ist dass man alles sieht auch bei auch bei nacht ansonsten bräuchte es wie irgendwie
infrarot geschiss und so dann wird es größer ne da bei 0 hat damit überhaupt keine probleme
das ist das kleinste problem so also wo sind wir jetzt stehen geblieben also genau so funktioniert
das mit so funktioniert das mit der klingel und dementsprechend ist das auch das was ich
hier nachgebaut habe so als simulator so und was ich hier auch noch dran habe ist folgendes
deswegen gibt es ja auch ein kleines delay ist die kamera gut genug für gesichtserkennung
für deinen vater wie ne das funktioniert nicht aber das also wenn der vor der tür
steht das würde ich auch das würde ich auch erkennen ohne gesichtserkennung aber ja wenn
die kamera in sagen wir so in der passenden höhe hängen würde dass man darauf die gesichter
gut erkennt dies die ist eher so ein bisschen schräg das sieht man nicht richtig gut dann
würde das würde die qualität ausreichen ja so also und was ich jetzt halt hier noch
gemacht habe ist einmal es gibt halt diesen anruf es gibt halt den anruf wenn einer klingelt
und ich habe noch ein raspberry pi dran hängen in diesem ganzen ding den sieht man jetzt
hier nicht der raspberry pi erkennt der hat einen analog digital konverter dran und er
erkennt anhand der spannung auf dieser auf auf der siebener das ist eins dass sieben
auf sieben ob geklingelt wurde oder nicht und das ist ungefähr zwei sekunden schneller
wieder deck telefonanruf deswegen habe ich das hier auch so jetzt gebaut zum simulieren
das wenn ich den button klicke dann wirft es einen event es hat geklingelt dann warten
wir 2,5 sekunden und dann macht der ersten anruf das ganze geht übrigens alles über
meine lokale fritz box dann macht der ersten anruf also um das ganze zu simulieren so also
was wir jetzt probieren ist der reihe der der reihe nach also was wir jetzt probieren
ist probieren ist folgendes als erstes probieren wir mal audio aus es wird sieben dankeschön
für den für den sub also als erstes als erstes probieren wir mal audio aus das heißt ich
gucke jetzt mal dass ich es irgendwie schaffe wenn ich mich hier mit meinem fritz phone hier
dem da hört man das wenigstens wenn ich wenn ich da drauf wenn ich wenn ich da hört man
das wenigstens piepsen wenn ich da drauf klicke so jetzt hier das ist die des neuestes
neuestes suppression ist echt gut aber das hört man so also ich werde das jetzt so machen
dass ich mich hier anmelde an der fritz box und ich dann mit dem fritz phone anrufen kann
und also das ist der erste schritt wir bauen hier einen zip server oder wie auch immer
man das nimmt nennt der wir machen das übrigens nicht mit mit visual studio wir machen das
mit rider warum sollte man das visual studio machen hackway hackway moment ich hab kein
rider installiert natürlich habe ich rider installiert what ich hab das eben aufgehabt
auf dem anderen account kann es sein dass es lokal installiert ist bei mir auf dem anderen
account weil ich ich könnte es übrigens unter linux machen stimmt warum soll man das eigentlich
unter windows machen wir machen das unter linux weil ich das mit der toolbox installiert
habe kann das sein dass die toolbox dass die toolbox nur lokal für den jeweiligen user
installiert wir machen das unter linux warum soll man das eigentlich unter windows machen
wo
Wo liegt denn die V.M.?
Was ist da jetzt kaputt?
V.M. wäre Lockstation.
Wo liegt...
E Doppelpunkt V.M.s.
Ach, das liegt im Main-Verzeichnis.
Warum liegt denn das im Main-Verzeichnis?
Warum habe ich denn das nicht in irgendwas Unterverzeichn... nicht... Verzeichnicheres...
Warum liegt denn das im Main-Verzeichnis drin?
Das ist ja richtig hängen geblieben.
Geht, geht denn zum Beispiel die Qt.V.M. an?
Ja, die geht. Okay.
Jaja.
Ähm, okay.
L-Lock.
Ähm... kann man das Lock-File einfach löschen?
Ich lösche das Lock-File jetzt alles mal.
Ist sonst noch... seht ihr sonst noch irgendwelche Lock-Files?
Mit Viertelbox wäre das nicht passiert.
Tja.
Und? Pause-Jam? Pause-Jam?
Ah, das sieht gut aus.
Okay, was auch immer das jetzt gewesen ist.
Keine Ahnung.
War doch nicht Layer 8.
Das war doch eindeutig irgendein V.M.-Werfehler.
Layer 8 wär's gewesen, hätt ich den falschen Knopf gedrückt oder so.
So.
Ach nee!
Leute, warum soll ich das...
Sie sind doch bescheuert.
Natürlich kann ich das nicht unter Linux machen.
Seit wann funktioniert Windows Forms unter Linux?
Der Chat wieder.
Was ist der Chat wieder für Dinge erzählen?
Stimmt wieder überhaupt nicht.
Ich... Anzeige ist raus.
So.
Warum hab ich Ryla nicht installiert, was?
Ich brauch ne ordentliche Idee.
Ich krieg Anfälle mit...
Okay, ich installier das jetzt.
Ich download das jetzt einfach nochmal neu.
So.
Beißt sich das jetzt irgendwie mit Toolbox-Installation und...
Wobei man kann das doch... Moment.
Ich installier mir jetzt einfach die Toolbox.
Äh...
Toolbox.
JetBrains.
Hätt ich jetzt nicht gedacht, dass ich das machen muss, aber gut ist.
Gibt's das auch...
Gibt's das auch auf Englisch?
Dann installier ich da drüber.
JetBrains installiert sich in Local...
Data.
Tja, gut.
Wie heißt der jetzt? Ich will's nicht auf Deutsch, please.
Lass es doch einfach hier da.
Sprache, Englisch.
Excellent.
Download. Bam.
Ja gut, dann installier ich es halt hier nochmal.
Hab ich genug Festplattenplatz?
Bei mir ist es auf der SSD ein bisschen eng, muss ich sagen.
920G.
Ja.
Sollte reichen.
Schon Grinch Max, warum die schwimmen?
Ja, warum die schwimmen, genau.
Warum nicht Emacs?
Generell sind alle grafischen Editoren bloated.
Also ich mach prinzipiell eigentlich alles nur mit Seed und AWK.
Es ist alles bloated.
Und wisst ihr was am aller bloatesten ist?
Das aller bloateste ist ein Browser zu verwenden, um Twitch zu gucken.
Man kann das genauso gut auf der Konsole gucken.
Mit, ähm...
Stream Download.
Stream Download zu ASCII-Video.
Warum sollte man überhaupt im Browser so Dinger machen?
Das ist weirdchamp.
Weirdchamp, Alter.
Wer guckt Twitch bitte schön im Browser?
Was seid ihr für Hacker-Mans?
Gab's Windows Forms nicht für Mono?
Ja, wir nehmen.NET Core und nicht Mono.
So, also.
Install, weiter.
Bam.
Dann mach ma.
Musik wieder.
Hier, Pippe.
Pippe, please.
So, machen wir schon mal zu und hoffen, dass es da mit Ryder ordentlich funktioniert.
So, Toolbox.
Gib uns.
Hardly looks.
Bald ist Talk Like a Pirate Day, hab ich gesehen.
App ist ja noch mehr bloat.
Also, die Stufe ist ganz, ganz klar.
App ist da meist bloat.
Weil du was zusätzliches brauchst.
Browser gucken ist minimal weniger bloat.
Aber nur, wer richtig gut mit ASCII, äh, mit Video zu ASCII guckt, der ist unbloated unterwegs.
Gibt's bestimmt auch irgendeinen Emacs Plugin für Twitch mittlerweile.
Gibt es einen Emacs?
Moment, das muss ich jetzt mal gucken.
Das war klar.
Es gibt eigentlich nichts, was es für Emacs nicht gibt.
Nein, das brauchen wir nicht.
Ja, mach.
Apply.
Oh.
Admin.
Oh man, da hat man Rechte für.
DeadBrands.
Wunderbar.
Excellent.
Weiter.
Weiter starten.
Hat er jetzt die Lizenz mit übernommen oder nicht?
Ich hoffe, dass er die Lizenz mit übernommen hat.
Okay, Open.
Ryder Projects.
Klingelchamp.
Klar.
Jaja.
Trust.
So.
Hab einen Vortrag gesehen über Hardware-Hacking.
Der Typ hat PCI-Express-Man in der Mitte gemacht.
Was zum Teufel?
Ja, gibt's so Leute.
Gab's die Probe-Klausur, die mal einge...
Ach, stimmt.
Das hab ich ganz vergessen.
Nein, die gab's noch nicht.
Hab ich gar nicht mehr dran gedacht.
Stimmt.
Die können wir uns demnächst auch mal angucken.
Ich kann nicht alles immer instant machen.
Das war Java, hab ich aber gesehen.
Wir werden das nicht in Java machen.
Das kann ich euch gleich sagen.
Die Probe-Klausur war in Java.
Wir machen das in einer ordentlichen Programmiersprache.
Nicht, nicht, nicht hier.
Außerdem kann ich kein Java.
Und auch nicht in C++.
Ich hasse C++.
C++ ist so eine scheiß Programmiersprache.
Der Wahnsinn, dass so viele Leute...
So.
Also.
Terminal.
.net, run.
Was, das not exist?
Ach so, der Klingel-Champ ist da.
So, jetzt.
Run.
Alles klar.
So, funktioniert.
Simulator.
Alles im grünen Bereich.
Gut.
Jetzt können wir anfangen.
Also, mit was wir anfangen, ist Folgendes.
Nur mal zum Warmwerden.
Also, als erstes probieren wir mal Sound.
Von hier.
Das muss ich aber dann mit dem Fritz-Phone simulieren.
Ansonsten müsste ich gucken, wie ich da Winde aus Headset-Audio rein bekomme.
Und ich glaube, das wollen wir jetzt nicht ausprobieren an der Stelle.
Ja, an der Stelle.
Genau, also das erste, was wir probieren, ist...
...diesen Anruf von der Klingel.
Das muss ich aber dann mit dem Fritz-Phone simulieren.
Ansonsten müsste ich gucken, wie ich da Winde aus Headset-Audio rein bekomme.
Und ich glaube, das wollen wir jetzt nicht ausprobieren an der Stelle.
Genau, also das erste, was wir probieren, ist...
...diesen Anruf von der Klingel.
Das mache ich hier mit einem Decktelefon stellvertretend für die Klingel.
Decktelefon Sound zu irgendeinem...
Also erstmal gucken, dass er den Anruf mitbekommt.
Irgendeinem...
Komm, das ist das erste.
Wir registrieren uns an der Fritz-Box und gucken, dass er den Anruf mitbekommt.
Ich glaube, das können wir jetzt mal relativ einfach machen.
Also, gehen wir mal hier rein, machen irgendwie eine neue Datei.
Add.
File.
Tja, wie nennen wir das jetzt?
Was weiß ich?
0W.
Mir fällt jetzt gar...
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, was ich da drin überhaupt basteln werde.
Also, wir bauen jetzt mal irgendwie so eine Art...
Wir brauchen keinen extra File.
Wir machen das einfach alles in Main rein.
Easy.
Warum sollten wir das irgendwo...
Wobei, vielleicht ist das doch keine so gute Idee.
Single Threaded?
Okay, vielleicht mach ich das doch extra.
Egal.
Wir schreiben das jetzt einfach in Main rein und gut ist.
Oder machen wir das jetzt?
Wir machen jetzt Big Prane.
Main.
So.
Nee, das geht ja nicht.
Das kann man nicht.
Real Main, Alter.
Perfekt.
So brauchen wir das.
So muss das sein.
Okay.
So ist das gut.
Das, so wollte ich das schon immer haben.
Real Main.
So muss das sein.
Also, wir registrieren uns jetzt an der Fritzbox.
Ich hab ein extra Account gemacht für die Fritzbox, wo wir uns anmelden können.
Und zwar, ich hab zwei Accounts.
Einmal mein Simulations-Account.
Der Simulations-Account hier.
Fake Door.
Passwort CACW0123.
Und...
Jetzt brauchen wir einen richtigen Account.
Die muss die Funktion nicht Static sein.
Doch, doch, aber die hier ist Static.
Die Main-Funktion hier in meiner Custom-Klasse, die einfach nur Fake Main heißt, ist nicht.
Ich nenn's vielleicht mal Fake Main.
Egal.
Wir lassen das jetzt einfach so.
Real Main ist das jetzt.
Wie?
Ach so.
Ja klar.
Das geht ja nicht, weil das sonst der Constructor wäre.
Jaja, ist gut.
Also, wir melden uns jetzt mal an der Fritzbox an.
Dafür hab ich ein extra User auf meiner Fritzbox angelegt.
Das wird euch freuen, wie der User heißt.
Geh ich mal von aus.
Der User heißt QtPhone69.
Und hat ein Passwort von, also auf der Fritzbox.
Und hat ein Passwort von, ja im Prinzip das gleiche wie das andere.
So, und die interne Telefonnummer.
Die brauch ich nicht, die notier ich mir jetzt hier plus mal.
Die interne Telefonnummer von QtPhone69 ist 621.
Sagt die Fritzbox.
Was macht das Add von den Strings?
Sonderzeichen eskäpen, aber das brauch ich an der Stelle gar nicht.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn du, ich zeig dir das mal.
Also im Angenommnis sagst du null, Backslash keqw, dann mag der das nicht.
Weil Backslash standardmäßig das K eskept.
Und K ist halt kein gültiger eskept.
So, Backslash N wäre zum Beispiel gültiger eskept.
So, was man jetzt machen kann ist, wenn ich diese Sonderzeichen,
diese eskept Sachen gar nicht benutze, mach ich ein Add davor.
Und dann zählt das eben nicht als eskept, sondern als ganz normaler Backslash.
Man kann glaube ich hier drinnen doch dann irgendwas eskepen.
Aber frag mich nicht aus dem Kopf, wie es geht.
Ich glaube man muss es doppelt machen oder so.
Also wenn ich jetzt hier drin was eskepen muss.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube es ging irgendwie.
Egal.
Im Prinzip ist es aber ganz einfach.
Man benutzt einfach das hier, es sei denn man braucht wirklich die eskept Geschichten.
Und übrigens die andere.
Ne, ne doppelter Backslash ist es nicht.
Backslash, Backslash ist ja hierdurch durch aufgehoben.
Ne, ne.
Das ging glaube ich trotzdem irgendwie.
Ich glaube irgendwie, irgendwie so.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Also zum Beispiel wenn ich jetzt hier Quads rein machen will, muss ich die doppelt machen.
Guck, das funktioniert.
Wohin ging hier oben, wenn ich da Quads rein machen will?
Dann muss ich das eskepen.
Achso, hier habe ich ein Add davor.
So, muss ich das eskepen.
So viel dazu.
Dann gibt es noch ein neues C Sharp Feature.
Das muss ich an der Stelle auch mal ansprechen, wenn wir gerade schon dabei sind.
Es gibt seit, ich glaube C Sharp 7, bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher.
Proc.
Eine Proc Funktion.
Man kann jetzt neben Add und nicht Add kann man noch Dollar verwenden.
Und Dollar sind Format Strings.
Also dann kann ich sowas hier machen zum Beispiel.
Hallo.
Und hier kann man jetzt Variablen einsetzen, zum Beispiel PW.
Das ist, äh, nice, nice.
Das ist praktisch.
So und das kann man übrigens kombinieren auch mit Add oder nicht Add.
Wobei ich glaube es egal ist, ob man das Add davor oder danach macht.
Ich meine, für Strings in Strings, in dem Fall ist es jetzt, ja, die sind ja nicht dynamisch, dann ist es relativ sinnlos.
Da könnte ich das auch so reinschreiben.
Aber sagen wir mal, ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel so ein Testobjekt.
Und da gibt es dann sowas wie, keine Ahnung, Start gleich Date, Time, Now, Name gleich Cute, Chat und sowas drin.
So und wenn ich das Objekt habe und das jetzt ordentlich formatiert ausgeben will, dann könnte ich jetzt hier sagen,
ok, Testobjekt, Start und hier Testobjekt, Name. So und das würde dann funktionieren.
Und übrigens, wer sich jetzt fragt, und wer sich jetzt fragt, was das hier ist, das ist ein anonymer, steht glaube ich sogar da.
Oder auch nicht.
Das ist ein anonymer Typ, der macht, der Compiler, der C Sharp Compiler ist Big Brain.
Der anonyme Typen sind richtig alt, gibt es glaube ich seit C Sharp 4 oder seit.NET Framework 3 oder so, das ist uralt.
Aber das ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch, wenn man einfach ein paar Sachen gruppieren will und da kein extra Klasse oder Structure anlegen will.
Der Compiler macht unter der Haube da raus ein extra Objekt.
Also sprich, wenn ihr euch mal den IL Code decompilert, da kommt dann so Sachen raus wie Class, XYZ, 123, was auch immer.
Und ja, so funktioniert das.
Machen wir das mal weg. So, kommen wir mal zur Telefonanlage.
Oh, Joel hat mich geredet, 686 Leute, Dankeschön. Huge. Massive. Raid hier. Sixhead Raid.
Ja, also ich glaube ich habe die Fragen jetzt beantwortet, ich bin ein bisschen abgeschweift zu der ganzen Geschichte.
So, also machen wir jetzt mal mit der eigentlichen Telefonanlagen-Geschichte weiter.
Also Ziel ist es ja, ich kann es jetzt nochmal, also ich werde es mal für alle, die jetzt neu dabei gekommen sind, kurz erklären, was ich vorhabe.
Und zwar, ich habe, wir werden hier nie geradet, ab und zu, wir raiden eher andere Leute.
Also ich habe etwas, wie soll man sagen, provisorisches gebaut.
Und zwar, das bleibt nicht so, mittlerweile ist das im Keller. Also ich habe eine Tür-Gegensprechanlage und die Tür-Gegensprechanlage soll mich auf dem Handy anrufen können.
Das funktioniert prinzipiell auch. Das geht quasi dann hier von der Tür, also mittlerweile liegt das im Keller.
Das geht von der Tür-Gegensprechanlage an so einen Türklingel zu Telefonanruf-Umwandler.
Dann geht das hier in so einen deckt, analog zu deckt Telefonen-Converter dran und von da zur Fritzbox.
So, und was ich jetzt machen will, ist folgendes. Ich habe einmal eine Raspberry Pi-Kamera.
Du hast mich vorgeschlagen. Big brain suggestion hier. Nice.
Also ich habe eine Kamera am Hoftor mit dem Raspberry Pi und eben die Tür-Klingel.
Und jetzt will ich kombinieren das Bild von der Raspberry Pi-Kamera und die Sprache von der Tür-Klingel-Gegensprechanlage in einen Anruf auf mein Handy.
Hört sich jetzt erstmal kompliziert an, aber ich habe es im Vorfeld ausprobiert. Prinzipiell funktioniert das.
So, und ich baue das jetzt hier im Stream einfach nochmal nach und erkläre ein bisschen was dabei.
Wir sind hier gerade bei dem allerersten Part. Wir versuchen uns an der Fritzbox anzumelden.
Das ist in der Tat relativ easy. Und das Schöne ist, dadurch, dass ich etwas vorbereitet habe, kann ich jetzt abgucken.
Genau, also ich habe einen User auf der Fritzbox angelegt. User Qtphone69, Passwort, das da. Jetzt muss ich mich anmelden.
So, und was man bei ZIP wissen muss ist, also ZIP ist ja dieses Voice over IP Protokoll Zeugs da.
Was man bei ZIP wissen muss, wusste ich auch nicht, bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt, wo ich mich damit beschäftigt habe, ist, bei ZIP läuft das so ab.
Also, wenn ihr euch schon mal gefragt habt, keine Ahnung, was gibt es da so? Was sind denn so Standard ZIP-Klines, die man verwendet?
Gibt es Leute, die überhaupt ZIP-Klines verwenden? Normalerweise... Was gibt es denn da so?
Nicht Skype, äh, Linphone oder sowas zum Beispiel, ja?
7ZIP, genau. Celo ist wieder richtig big brain, massive unterwegs hier.
Phonolight, genau. Solche, solche, solche Dinger. Solche, solche Dinger meine ich.
Phonolight, sowas, sowas, genau.
So, und wer sich schon mal gefragt hat, wie das funktioniert, dass man sich da anmeldet bei irgendeinem ZIP-Anbieter und dann Anrufe bekommt, in Wirklichkeit sind das zwei Schritte.
Und zwar, damit man einen Anruf bekommt von ZIP, man muss sich erst registrieren, aber über diese Registrierung bekommt man keine Anrufe.
Man registriert sich nur und sagt dem Registrar, wo man erreichbar ist.
Also sprich, in Wirklichkeit macht die Fritzbox eigentlich gar nichts, außer registrieren.
Es sei denn, wenn du analoge Telefonen und so dran hast.
Also sprich, man meldet sich bei der Fritzbox an und das Einzige, was die Fritzbox sich merkt, ist, okay, dieser User ist unter dieser IP erreichbar.
Also mein Rechner würde sich jetzt registrieren bei der Fritzbox mit seiner lokalen IP und wenn die Fritzbox dann Anruf bekommt für den, dann würde es das an mich weiter schicken.
Okay, also, das machen wir jetzt mal.
Da muss ich mal kurz abgucken.
Genau, das funktioniert nämlich folgendermaßen.
Also, man muss erst mal sagen, man möchte eine ZIP-Registration machen.
Und dafür braucht man einen Transport.
Was auch immer ein Transport ist, habe ich bis heute nicht verstanden, aber wir machen einfach einen ZIP-Transport und gut ist, wenn die den Transport haben wollen, gehen die in den Transport.
So, und da kommen jetzt die Anmeldedaten hin von der Fritzbox.
Das heißt, als User, hugephone69 und als Passwort, das Passwort.
So, und dann, in welchem Interfall, das ich neu anmelden soll bei der Fritzbox, dann sagen wir einfach mal alle zwei Minuten.
So, und ich glaube, das war's jetzt.
Passt das jetzt?
Das muss eigentlich gewesen sein, ob man auch immer da jetzt hier keinen Bock hat.
Okay, wait.
Achso, Moment, ich brauche noch die, ich brauche noch die IP von der Fritzbox.
Oh, er weiß ja gar nicht, woran er sich registrieren soll. So, meine Fritzbox hat die IP.
Wir könnten es auch, wir könnten auch den Klassiker nehmen, fritz.box.
Obwohl ich mir da gar nicht sicher bin, ob das überhaupt auflöst.
Löst das bei mir auf? Tatsächlich, guck hier, IP.
Aber das ist gar nicht die Fritzbox, die das auflöst, das ist mein MikroTik-Router, der das auflöst.
IP, fuck, chat, chat, jetzt habe ich es geleakt, sei denn schon drin.
So, also jetzt können wir uns registrieren bei der Fritzbox.
Natürlich, natürlich ist der Chandler wieder als erstes drin, der hat mit sowas Erfahrung.
Also was das macht ist, das meldet sich bei der Fritzbox an und sagt, hey, ich bin erreichbar unter dieser IP.
So, und ich copypaste mir jetzt mal was aus meinem Testprogramm, weil ich das jetzt nicht alles tippen muss und wir einfach sehen können, ob es funktioniert.
Dann mache ich es halt auch so. Genau, also, der startet jetzt Registrierung bei der Fritzbox.
Und im Fehlerfall gibt er aus, Registrierung kaputt oder sagt, Registrierung hat funktioniert.
Was meckert Ryder eigentlich? Nein, ich habe dafür keine Übersetzung eingebaut.
Schauen wir das jetzt mal aus, ob das funktioniert.
Nein.
Warum nicht?
Warum funktioniert das jetzt nicht?
Das ist die beste Debug Ausgabe überhaupt.
Der startet Real Main nicht. Warum startet er nicht Real Main?
Der soll gefälligst Real Main starten. Was ist denn hier?
Anzeige ist raus. Warum macht er das denn nicht?
Weil es nicht fertig ist. Nee, mit New sollte er das eigentlich schon erkennen.
Häh? Sekunde. Ich, ihr wisst, ich bin kein Fan von Breakpoints, lul. Der führt die... What? Der führt das gar nicht aus?
Wie der führt Main nicht aus?
Was?
Moment. Ich bin... Häh?
Habe ich jetzt irgendwas... Restore? Habe ich irgendwas vergessen?
Chat, ihr wisst es auch nicht. Tut nicht so.
Das funktioniert.
Ach so. Ja, ich weiß woran es liegt. Guck mal. Ich mach doch meine Konsole erst auf. Ich mach doch meine Konsole erst auf in der Form.
So, die Konsole muss ich natürlich hier schon aufmachen.
Ja, das ist es.
Deswegen gibt er da auch nichts aus. Funktioniert hätte es wahrscheinlich.
Ja, jetzt funktioniert... Oh ja, Konsole in groß muss unbedingt sein. Jetzt wird es auch funktionieren. Real Main.
Zip, also wir haben uns succesfull registriert an der Fritzbox. Qtphone69 at fritz.box registration succeeded. Das heißt, die Fritzbox weiß jetzt, dass wir erreichbar sind unter der IP von meinem Rechner, wenn wir Anrufe bekommen.
Ja, wir können auch ausprobieren, ob es prinzipiell funktioniert. Ich ruf mich mal an, hier mit dem Fritzbox. Und zwar Sternchen, Sternchen 621 is Qtphone69.
Und es wird nichts passieren, weil wir noch nicht registriert haben, was wir machen wollen, wenn wir einen Anruf bekommen. Das müssen wir jetzt noch machen.
Wir haben jetzt aktuell nur uns bei der Fritzbox angemeldet. Gut, weiter im Text.
Ich muss übrigens gerade überlegen, ob das so eine gute Idee ist, wenn ich das immer Ctrl-C. Ob ich das nicht vielleicht irgendwie disposen sollte oder so. Muss man das disposen? Weiß nicht.
Na schauen wir mal. Also wir haben uns angemeldet bei der Fritzbox. Okay, damit wir jetzt einen Anruf bekommen können, müssen wir einen Zip Agent anlegen, weil Zip so funktioniert.
Man könnte übrigens auch noch den Port hier angeben. Also hier könnte man übrigens auch angeben, Transport, ob man TCP oder UDP verwenden will.
Ach nee, hier. Zip, TCP, Transport und sowas. Aber das brauchen wir nicht. Standard reicht. Standard ist UDP und das ist für Audio, Audiozeug auch absolut in Ordnung.
Übrigens, richtig geile, ich hatte heute wieder ein richtiges WeirdChamp Meeting auf der Arbeit. Also Massive WeirdChamp. So sinngemäß, ihr wisst, ich erzähle das immer nicht mit genauem Namen von Leuten und ich passe da manche Leute auch in zwei Personen zusammen.
Prinzipiell ging das so nach dem Motto, oh mein Gott, Microsoft verliert Pakete von uns. Also es geht um Netzwerkpakete. Über wie viel reden wir? Über wie viel reden wir?
Da meint ihr, dreimal seit Juni. Oh nein, das ist aber ganz schön viel. Und jetzt schieben sie Panik, jetzt schieben sie Panik, ob dadurch nicht unser DNS kaputt geht.
Drei Probleme seit Juni. Was erwarten die denn von Microsoft?
Übrigens, es waren nicht wirklich drei Pakete, muss man dazu sagen, dreimal gab es Probleme seit Juni. Und da habe ich dann gemeint, wurde dafür nicht TCP erfunden? Und irgendwie wollte da drüber keiner mehr reden.
Da meinte ich, ja aber TCP Timer auch noch fünf Minuten. Keine Ahnung. Ich habe da so meine Zweifel, dass das überhaupt irgendwelche Auswirkungen haben wird. Aber egal, wir wollten uns bei der Fritzbox anmelden.
Also wir haben hier einmal den Agent, um uns zu registrieren bei der Fritzbox. Jetzt brauchen wir noch einen, nennen wir den mal User Agent. Das ist der, den wir verwenden, um Calls zu empfangen. TCP ist bloat. TCP ist ja alles bloat.
Generell, jegliche Portokolle sind bloat. Man braucht eigentlich nur einen Kabel. Ist in irgendeiner Art und Weise dort strukturiert Datenschreiben schon bloat?
Muss man da, müsste man da nicht mit irgendwie direkt mit irgendeinem Spannungswandler dahinter irgendwas machen? Also ich glaube, ich glaube schon Datenübertragung ist eigentlich bloat.
Allein schon davon auszugehen, das digital zu übertragen, ist ja schon bloat. Einfach analog wie früher. Ging auch. Und geht muss man ehrlich sagen in manchen Bereichen auch besser.
Also New, ZIP, User Agent. So, da müssen wir den gleichen Transport verwenden, für das registrieren. Sonst funktioniert das nicht. So und wir brauchen kein Proxy.
So und jetzt können wir sagen, hey, wenn wir angerufen werden, On Incoming Call, da machen wir mal neue Methode hier. User Agent On Incoming Call, ja wunderbar.
ZIP Agent und Request. So und wenn wir jetzt einen Call bekommen, Call ist da am Start, 0W. Jetzt starten wir das mal und wenn das jetzt alles funktioniert,
dann Fritzbox Registration succeeded. Wenn das alles funktioniert und ich rufe jetzt auf dem Telefon, Sternchen, Sternchen, 621 an, dann sollte da stehen, Call ist da am Start, 0W.
Also dann hat das Programm gecheckt, dass wir angerufen wurden. So, probieren wir mal aus. Call. Call ist da am Start, 0W. Geht. Bekommt mit, dass es klingelt.
Sehr schön. Gut. Also, wir haben uns registriert an der Fritzbox und wir bekommen mit, wenn uns jemand anruft. Also jetzt muss ich mal überlegen, was wir als nächstes machen.
Also Leute, ich weiß, was wir machen. Ich weiß, was wir machen. Wir installieren uns ein ZIP Programm. Wir installieren uns irgendwie Linphone oder so.
Das können wir glaube ich hier aus den Repos installieren. Und dann versuchen wir mal, dass ich in meinem Telefon reden kann und ihr mich hört.
Also wir fordern mal irgendwie Sprache von einem Klein zum anderen. Mal gucken, ob ich das gebacken bekomme. Also ich weiß ja prinzipiell, wie das funktioniert.
Aber ich will jetzt auch nicht alles copypasten. So, Linphone, Download, Linux. Was sind die aktuelle Version? Ja, ja, ok. Was auch immer.
4, 2, 5. Jetzt war eine dumme Frage. Wenn 4, 2, 5 das aktuelle ist, warum gibt es dann hier 4, 3? Ach, Alpha. Nee. 5 sogar.
Ok, was? Ich glaube, ich mach jetzt mal das, was man unter Linux eigentlich normalerweise nicht macht. Ich lad mir was von der offiziellen Seite runter.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was ich da für komische Dinger im Repo drinne hab. Ich hätte schon irgendwie gerne was, was halbwegs funktioniert.
CHMOD plus X, Linphone. Linphone. Perfekt, da sind wir. So, Linphone muss ich nirgendwo registrieren. Man kann lokal anrufen. Hier. Einfach maxed 192.168.2.132. Gut.
Also, von der Idee her sind wir jetzt an dieser Stelle. Also, ich ruf an. Die Fritzbox, also Tür klingelt, leitet an die Fritzbox weiter.
Fritzbox leitet das Gespräch an mich weiter, an mein Programm. Und das Programm erkennt, dass es angerufen wird.
So, das heißt, jetzt muss ich den Call accepten und dann das Audio aus diesem Call weiterleiten in einem neuen Call an mein Linux Softphone.
Also, gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert. Leute, ich guck gleich Chat durch. Ich muss mich gerade ein bisschen konzentrieren.
Also, das Einfachste, was wir machen können, ist einfach einen neuen Call aufmachen und erstmal gucken, ob es funktioniert.
Ob es funktioniert, dass wenn ich mich anrufe mit meinem Fritzphone, dass es dann hier klingelt auf der Linux-Kiste.
Das probiere ich jetzt mal aus. Also, es sollte auf der Linux-Kiste jetzt gleich klingeln, wenn ich mich anrufe.
Also, wenn ich nicht die Linux-Kiste anrufe, sondern mein Programm anrufe, den Call vom Fritzphone weiterleiten.
Gucken wir mal. Gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
Also, wie würden wir das jetzt machen? Machen wir jetzt Agent? Agent on incoming call.
Wir müssen den Call accepten. Muss ich mal kurz gucken, wie das funktioniert. On incoming call.
Okay, dann schreiben wir mal hin. On call, dass wir wissen, wo wir sind.
So, und jetzt muss ich das Gespräch irgendwie annehmen. Wie ging das denn jetzt nochmal?
Agent, ich glaube, es gibt sowas wie accept. Accept call, genau. Request, okay. Angenommen.
Wir nehmen den Call an. Und da schreiben wir drunter irgendwie, keine Ahnung, call accepted, dass wir wissen, was es treibt.
So, und als nächstes. Hast du ein Menu unternehmen oder weißt du die Befehle aus, wenn ich...
Ich habe im Vorfeld schon mal was gebastelt, wo ich nachgucken kann.
Weil ansonsten müsste ich das jetzt aus dem Kopf auch nicht. Da müsste ich...
Es ist ja so, wenn ich normalerweise sowas bastelt, dann bin ich permanent bei denen auf GitHub in irgendwelchen Examples.
In dem Fall weiß ich so grob, was ich machen muss.
So, und jetzt muss man, deshalb das verstehe ich jetzt nicht, also ich verstehe nicht, warum accept call nicht ausreicht.
Keine Ahnung. Jetzt muss ich sagen, agent, answer, weil, weil auch immer, accept call reicht bei zip anscheinend nicht.
Ja, ist ja klar, er ist mod. Er war ganz am Anfang mal da.
Warum das nicht reicht, ja ich weiß es nicht. Accept call ist nicht, ist anscheinend bei zip logic nicht genug, keine Ahnung.
Also, ich muss jetzt sagen, agent, answer und dann, lass mich mal kurz abgucken.
What the fuck. Ich copy paste mir das jetzt einfach mal.
So, bam.
So, was ist das? Alter, ich habe das zwar schon mal fertig programmiert hier, dass es grob funktioniert, aber ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich da gemacht habe.
Decked Media Session. Was ist das?
Sowas habe ich doch hier auch schon irgendwo.
Media Session. Audio only Media Session. Ja, meinetwegen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was es gibt. So, also, accept call.
Gut, das heißt, wenn ich jetzt anrufe, dann sollte eigentlich der Call, ihr seht es jetzt nicht, aber dann sollte eigentlich der Call von meinem Fritzbox angenommen werden.
Gucken wir mal. Ja, funktioniert.
Call wird angenommen. Sehr schön.
Moin, wie machst du das mit Linux und Windows parallel in Betrieb? Ich habe vor allem ein Workstation auf.
Und habe Linux unter Windows virtualisiert. Ich habe es aber auf dem zweiten Desktop.
Das zweite Desktop kannst du hier durchswitchen über Windows oder du machst Control, Windows-Taste.
Feil links, feil rechts. Da kannst du durchswitchen.
Und wenn du vor allem ein Workstation auf dem zweiten Desktop hast, klickst du da einfach rein und bist hier wieder am Start.
Hast du vor allem 16 oder 15? Ich glaube sogar noch 14. Ich glaube, das ist noch vor allem 14.
So, und jetzt lassen wir es klingeln. Und jetzt lassen wir es klingeln auf meinem Linux Agent und versuchen, das irgendwie irgendwie weiter weiterzuleiten.
Anderes Level Agile-ness. Ja, Massive. Es ist so unglaublich Agile alles. Agiler, Agiler kann es dir eigentlich kaum noch sein.
Ich sehe jetzt schon ein Problem, weil das funktioniert bei mir auch nicht so richtig.
In dem, was ich gebast habe, das Weiterleiten vom Audio. Da gibt es irgendwie ein Problem. Ich leite ja das Audio dann an mein Handy weiter.
Da gibt es irgendwie ein Buffer-Problem und manchmal knackt es und manchmal klappt es gar nicht.
Mal schauen. Wir versuchen das einfach mal hinzubekommen.
So, also Call Accepted. Und jetzt muss ich einen neuen Call zu meinem Linux-Dings hier Agent-Agent machen.
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, ob ich nicht den gleichen Agent dafür noch mal verwenden kann.
Vielleicht funktioniert das. Probieren wir mal aus.
Also MaxEd1221682.132. Wollen wir anrufen? MaxEd1221682.132.
Ist das nicht Parallels? Nein, Quatsch. Das ist Vmware Workstation. Parallels ist von Vmware Workstation. Er ist von Vmware.
Nee, Fusion ist von Vmware. Wartet mal. Moment.
Übrigens, mein Chat ist gerade gecrashed auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Ich sehe jetzt nichts. Hat Twitch gerade Probleme oder so?
Hallo, was ist denn das hier jetzt? Ah, jetzt geht es wieder. Nee, nee. Nichts stream off.
So, ich versuche mal hier anzurufen, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Also sprich, wenn ich mit meinem Fritz vorne anrufe, dass es dann auf der anderen Seite klingelt.
Mal gucken, ob das klappt. Weil das mache ich bei mir anders.
Kein Username, kein Passwort. Ja, Media Session. Meinetwegen machen wir halt noch eine. Lull.
Temp. Temp ist immer prinzipiell das beste.
Temp.
So, also das sollte jetzt eigentlich callen. Result gleich.
Wait. Result. Okay, mal gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Ich rufe mich jetzt an mit meinem Fritz vor und mal gucken, ob das, ob das tut.
Ich rufe mich jetzt an mit meinem Fritz Fritz vor und dann sollte das hier klingeln.
Wahrscheinlich geht das jetzt nicht. Hey, Bam.
Funktioniert. Sehr schön.
Excellent. Easy as fuck.
Sonst wollte ich mich noch auflegen.
Also es funktioniert. Es funktioniert. Ich werde. Ich registriere mich an der Fritz Box als Cutephone69.
Kein Ton. Ton geht noch nicht. Mit Ton mache ich auch nichts.
Noch nicht. Machen wir jetzt als nächstes. Als nächstes machen wir Ton.
Aber bis jetzt ist das Ganze ja schon mal.
Außerdem ist Ton plottet. Genau.
Chat, jetzt mal eine Frage. Wir haben jetzt ja ganz oft erörtert heute schon, was alles plottet ist.
Sagt mir mal ein Beispiel für was nicht plottet ist. Was ist nicht plottet?
Wer kriegt das beste Beispiel, was nicht plottet ist?
Arch. Natürlich ist Arch plottet. Du hast einen Installer.
LFS. Okay, LFS lasse ich mir gefallen.
Grab. Natürlich ist Grab plottet. Grab hat Pearl Regex. Alles was Pearl Regex hat ist plottet.
Elektron. Ja, stimmt. Elektron ist komplett offensichtlich null plottet.
Der Kernel ist auch plottet.
Guck mal, was du da drei Mal dabei hast. Alles plottet.
AWK. AWK ist auch plottet.
Also ich würde mir gefallen lassen, wenn jemand sagt, Wim ist plottet, Vi ist nicht plottet.
Seht. Seht ist nicht plottet.
Ja, Cortana. Ja gut, Cortana ist tatsächlich nicht mehr plottet, weil Cortana verwendet keiner.
Gibt es irgendjemand von euch oder kennt ihr jemand, der Cortana verwendet?
Gibt es sowas?
AWK ist plottet. AWK kann schleifen. Alles was schleifen kann ist prinzipiell plottet.
Könnte man ja auch mit der Shell machen.
Wobei Shell an sich ist auch schon plottet.
Schleifen kann man außerdem manuell machen, genau.
Alles plottet.
Notepad. Der Notepad ist ja nur wirklich. Der plottet ist der Editor überhaupt.
Guck mal, ich zeig dir jetzt mal, warum das plottet ist.
Der kann verschiedene, wenn ich wüsste, wo das ist.
Der kann verschiedene Zeichenencodings. Alles außer ASCII ist plottet.
Ich weiß nicht, wo es funktioniert. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo man das hier einstellt, die Zeichenencodings.
Egal, genug dummes Zeug gelabert, Anruf funktioniert.
Und jetzt, und jetzt kommt massivst biggest brain time. Wir müssen irgendwie hinkriegen,
das Audio, das Audio von diesem Call zu transferieren auf diesen Call.
Also wir müssen, also ich nehme hier einen Call an vom Fritz-Phone und mache hier einen neuen Call auf meinen VoIP-Agent unter Linux.
Das heißt, wir müssen irgendwie, das sind zwei unterschiedliche ZIP-Calls.
Wir müssen irgendwie das Audio hier rausbekommen.
Genau, das ist das Diagramm von gestern, oder Diagramm.
Ich hätte mal ein besser Nassi Schneiderman Strukturgramm malen sollen, dann würden wir wenigstens durchblicken hier.
Oder Gant, ein Gant Diagramm. Was haltet ihr von einem Gant Diagramm, Leute?
So ein richtig schönes Gant Diagramm, wo sich gerade die IHK drüber freut.
Wobei ein Gant Diagramm für sowas eigentlich ziemlich sinnlos ist.
Also gibt es wirklich irgendjemand, der überhaupt Windows wäre nicht bloated?
Also big brain time. Ich zeige euch jetzt mal, wie ich das gemacht habe.
Also ich habe, wie gesagt, ich versuche jetzt nochmal kurz, ich habe einmal den Call vom Fritz-Phone,
ich benenne die Dinger mal so, dass man es versteht.
Ich benenne die Dinger mal so, dass man das geht.
Das hier ist Fritz, oder wie nennt man das Ding? Agent.
Das ist ja gar nicht der Agent, das ist ja, warte mal, eine Sekunde, mal kurz in mich gehen.
Das ist der Call, ja doch, das ist der Call vom Fritz-Phone.
Fritz-Phone-Phone-Call. Ich nenne das jetzt einfach, es stimmt zwar nicht genau,
aber es ist einfach nur, dass man das besser erkennt.
Das ist der Call vom Fritz-Phone und das hier ist, das muss ich jetzt auch anders nennen,
das hier ist der Voip-Call, oder wie nennen wir es denn?
Zip-Agent.
Ich glaube so, ich glaube so versteht man es dann besser.
Mal so gucken, ob das jetzt tut. Mal gucken, ob es noch geht.
Mal gucken, dass ich nicht kaputt gemacht habe.
Dinger, Dinger, 621, Call, Accept und es klingelt, alles klar, exellent.
Gut, jetzt haben wir das halbwegs gescheit benannt, alles ist gut.
So, das heißt ich muss jetzt irgendwie den Sound hier raus bekommen,
von dem Fritz-Phone-Call zu meinem Voip-Call und dann, dass ihr auch was hört.
Das Gequarium, Alter, Alza-Mixer ist es, glaube ich. Alza-Mixer.
Machen wir mal den Sound hier ein bisschen ruff, dass man was hört.
So, mal kurz YouTube-Test von der Sound-Lautstärke, ob das jetzt uns nicht die Ohren wegbläst.
Ja, nicht zu laut, wunderbar. Eigenwärmung, ja und?
Ist ja dann kein Problem drin. GrickyOMFG, danke schön für den Sub.
Und danke für die ganzen Subs, die ich heute zwischenzeitlich wieder übersehen habe.
So, okay, Leute, CacWade, auf geht's.
Also, wie ich das gemacht habe, den Sound zu transferieren, wir müssen ja nicht nur Sound transferieren.
Also, man muss zwei Sachen machen. Man muss die Sprache und den Sound transferieren.
Also, die Sprache vom Fritz-Phone muss man transferieren.
Und man muss die Rückantwort auch wieder zurück transferieren.
Ich glaube, man hat es jetzt halbwegs verstanden.
So, und wie das funktioniert, ist Folgendes.
Man kann, übrigens als Library verwende ich das hier. Das Ding ist richtig, richtig big brain.
Gibt es heute Predictions? Das können wir tatsächlich machen später.
Muss mal kurz gucken, wie viele es gerade sind. Ja, können wir später machen.
Zip-Sorcery, richtig nice Library.
Ich habe mal geguckt, was dahinter steckt.
Dahinter steckt irgendwie, also, für was sie das benutzen.
Das hier ist ganz normaler Zip-Code.
Die benutzen das für irgendeinen anonymen Bitcoin-bezahlbaren Telefonieservice.
Wer weiß, was für komische Dinger diese Anbieter von dieser Library damit machen.
Aber das ist mir egal. Ich verwende die Library einfach nur.
Und was die damit machen, ist ja für mich nicht relevant.
Allein schon, dass sowas nur Bitcoin bezahlt ist, weiß ich nicht.
Klingt irgendwie ein bisschen nach, vielleicht nicht ganz legalen Sachen.
Aber ich verwende nur die Library.
Das heißt, ich habe damit nichts zu tun, was die für einen Service damit anbieten.
Gut, also, okay, ich gehe jetzt mal in mich.
Also, was wir jetzt machen müssen, ist Folgendes.
Wir müssen dem sagen, hey, für den Call mit dem Fritz-Phone.
Für den Call mit dem Fritz-Phone muss man sagen, wir wollen eine VoIP-Media-Session.
Das heißt, wir wollen nicht nur Audio Only, sondern wir wollen Audiospraße und später auch Video und so.
So, und, ups, war jetzt irgendwas verkehrt.
So, New Media Endpoint.
So, und da kann man jetzt angeben, wohin die Daten geschickt werden sollen.
Man kann einmal angeben AudioSync und AudioSource und VideoSync und VideoSource.
AudioSync ist in dem Fall, wenn ich angerufen werde vom Fritz-Phone, ist AudioSync das, wo die Daten reingeschrieben,
also die Sprachdaten, die vom Fritz-Phone kommen, reingeschrieben werden.
Und AudioSource ist das, was ich zum Fritz-Phone schicke.
Also, was ich zum Fritz-Phone schicke.
Also sprich, AudioSource ist in dem Fall, also das, was vom Fritz-Phone kommt.
So, und AudioSource ist das, was ich zum Fritz-Phone schicke.
So, und damit das Ganze funktioniert, müssen wir jetzt einen eigenen, na ja, AudioDriver kann man das jetzt nicht nennen,
einen eigenen Audioimplementierung basteln dafür.
Das sind aber nur ein paar Zeilen, was diese Library versteht.
Dafür brauchen wir eine neue Klasse, die heißt, äh, tja, AudioSyncSource.
Mir fällt dann wirklich nichts anderes ein.
Die nimmt halt Audio an und gibt Audio wieder aus. Fertig.
So, und die brauche ich jetzt als Interface, iAudioSync und iAudioSource.
Audio, AudioBridge, das ist ein guter Name. Das finde ich nice. Audio.
Audio.
Okay, das ist ein AudioBedgil, aber das ergibt keinen Sinn. AudioBridge, das finde ich ist ein guter Name.
So, jetzt erstmal Interfaces implementieren lassen, automatisch von Rider.
Und sich erschrecken lassen, wieviel 3 Milliarden Methoden jetzt auf einmal auftauchen.
Bam!
Brauchen wir übrigens fast alles nicht. Ich sag nur mal, die Hälfte davon kannst du eigentlich komplett vergessen.
Ah, jetzt auch schon wieder so viel bloat, ja. Also AudioBridge, new file.
Okay, ich kann euch jetzt nämlich sagen, was wir davon brauchen.
Wir brauchen davon genau drei Zeilen oder so.
Da muss ich aber mal kurz, da muss ich mal kurz abgucken.
Check, ob ich denn.
Hier, also was wir brauchen davon ist folgendes.
Get Audio Sync Formats, das ist, was wir für Audio Codecs unterstützen.
Und wir unterstützen genau einen Audio Codec, also Return, New List Audio Format.
Deswegen mag ich Rider übrigens, weil das so geil das Autocomplete hat, das kann Wission Studio gar nicht.
Das ist richtig pock.
Also wir unterstützen genau ein Format, New Audio Format und das ist PCMU.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was es ist, aber ich glaube, das ist einfach Raw Waff Audio.
Also nix encodedes oder sonst wie einfach nur stinknormales Raw Audio.
Ohne irgendwelche Sperenzien.
Einfach Waff oder PCMA.
Nee, PCMA Braumer, du hast recht, PCMA Braumer, nicht PCMU.
PCMA Braumer, glaube ich, egal.
Weiß ich, dass es funktioniert.
Wir unterstützen nur Raw Audio, Waff, sonst nix.
Das A ist, glaube ich, welcher Byte Order ist, glaube ich, A oder U.
Ich glaube, das ist die Byte Order.
Keine Ahnung, weiß ich.
Wollen wir mal gucken, was der Unterschied ist.
PCMA versus PCMU.
Unterschied, PCMU.
Guck mal, welche aktuellen Codecs wir verwenden.
Es gibt Foren-Einträge von 2004.
Wir sind top aktuell.
Mr. Flöschin, ja nice, dass dir das gefällt.
Der Chat ist sich ja gerade noch ein bisschen unsicher, ob er der Sache folgen kann oder nicht.
Wobei ich sage, ich würde auch nicht mitkommen.
Also, was ist der Unterschied?
Also das einzige, was wir bis jetzt, ist das...
Was?
Oh, ah, Law?
Oh, Law?
Was zum?
Ah, yes, obvious, obvious.
Natürlich.
Also, also Chat, also Chat, ich glaube, das muss ich jetzt wirklich jetzt nicht erklären, oder?
Ich glaube, das sollte jeder verstehen.
Gut, weiter.
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung, was es...
Wir verwenden PCMA einfach.
Fertig.
Trivial, trivial.
AAC können die ganzen Dinger nicht.
Also, Audioformate, die prinzipiell möglich werden, sind die Dinger.
Die Dinger und...
JPG?
Ich glaube nicht, dass das Audioformate...
Ah, Mediaformate.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, seit wann ich JPG in einem Audioformat...
Haben wir auch GIF?
Nee.
GIF, wie die Kuhnohren.
GIF.
Audiowave-Überbilder.
So, also wir unterstützen nur...
Wir unterstützen nur PCMA.
So, wie gesagt, weiter im Text.
Diese Methode brauchen wir gar nicht.
Wir geben einfach das Audioformat aus, gut ist.
Die müssen wir gleich noch implementieren.
Das ist die einzige, wo wir was programmieren müssen.
Was heißt, was programmieren müssen?
Wir brauchen genau eine Zeile, die wir programmieren müssen.
Wir müssen nämlich sagen, on audio, encoded sample.
Wir müssen sagen, wenn wir...
Also, ich muss das jetzt mal kurz gleich erklären.
Also, das einzige, was wir hier machen, ist...
Wir bekommen hier Audio rein und geben das gleiche Audio wieder aus.
Das ist alles.
Deswegen sagen wir hier, sobald wir ein Audio-Paket bekommen...
Wir haben ein neues Audio-Sample bereit.
Also, wir machen eigentlich nichts anderes, wie...
Ein Audio-Paket bekommen und das Audio-Paket direkt wieder rausschicken.
Deswegen hält sich die Implementierung hier doch hart in Grenzen, was wir machen müssen.
So, pause audio, ganz einfach.
Return task completed.
Wir machen da gar nichts.
Task completed.
Resume audio, task completed.
Start audio, task completed.
Close audio, task completed.
Wir sagen einfach immer, wir hätten das gemacht, ohne was zu machen.
Audio source formats, das brauchen wir tatsächlich an der Stelle noch.
Und dort returnen wir wieder exakt das Gleiche, was wir oben auch zurückgegeben haben.
New audio format.
PCM.
Set audio.
Nix.
Restrict format.
External.
Nix.
Has encoded.
Oh, da muss man, glaube ich, was reinschreiben.
Zack has encoded.
Has encoded.
Ah.
Okay.
Has encoded subscribers.
Da muss ich return on.
Ob Leute subscriben zu dem Event, wofür die das brauchen.
Kein Schimmer.
So, is audio source paused.
Return.
Pulse.
Ne, true, true.
Immer, immer true.
True, 0W.
Einfach.
Ach, das hab ich sogar auf not implemented stehen.
Okay.
Restrict audio formats.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Pulse.
Return.
Task completed.
Also, man sieht schon, unsere Implementierung ist jetzt nicht, sondern nicht big brain.
So, fertig.
Mehr müssen wir nicht machen.
Also, das Einzige, was wir hier wirklich nennenswert, oder nicht mal nennenswert, programmiert haben, ist,
wir sagen, welche Audioformate wir unterstützen und das Audio, was wir reinschreiben, geben wir direkt wieder aus.
Fertig.
Mehr ist es nicht.
Gut.
Also, gehen wir mal zurück in unser real main.
Der Name, da mach ich immer noch fertig.
So.
Und jetzt legen wir mal die Audio-Session an für den Fritz-Phone-Call.
Also, das, was vom Fritz-Phone kommt, das heißt, wir legen jetzt mal einmal Audio-Bridge an.
Ne, wir brauchen einmal Fritz-Phone-To-Voip-New-Audio-Bridge.
Ups.
New Audio?
Also, was kommt denn da jetzt raus?
Microsoft Visual Basic Devices Audio.
Genau.
Das wollte ich jetzt unbedingt.
Audio-Bridge.
So, und dann brauchen wir noch eine zweite Audio-Bridge für den Rückweg, nämlich Voip-To-Fritz-Phone.
Ist ja logisch, ne?
Also, sprich, einmal brauchen wir die Sprache, die bei dem einen rauskommt, beim Fritz-Phone raus,
die Sprache, die beim Fritz-Phone reingeht, muss als Ausgabe in den Voip-Call hier und umgedreht.
Das, was hier reinkommt als Sprache, muss als Ausgang in das Fritz-Phone.
Wobei das mit der Sprache hier nicht funktioniert, weil ich hier kein Mikrofon dran habe.
Aber ihr könnt es dann gleich hören, ob es funktioniert.
So, das heißt, wir sagen jetzt hier Audio-Sync ist einmal in dem Fall hier Fritz-Phone-To-Voip.
So, und Audio-Source ist dementsprechend Voip.
Äh.
Ah, für das Komma.
Wo ist deine Audio-Bridge-Factory?
Das machen wir noch, wenn wir da richtig krasse Business-Applications draus erstellen.
So, jetzt ist das soweit einleuchtend.
Also sprich, die Session vom Fritz-Phone, die alles was rauskommt,
also alles was in das Mikrofon vom Fritz-Phone reingesprochen wird, geht in den Audio-Sync.
Also in Fritz-Phone-To-Voip.
Und alles was ich quasi ausgeben will über den Lautsprecher des Fritz-Phones,
ist hier in dem Fall Audio-Source, kommt von Voip und geht zum Fritz-Phone.
Also sprich, die Sprache vom Fritz-Phone geht vom Fritz-Phone zu der Voip-Verbindung.
Und das was am Fritz-Phone rauskommt, kommt von der Voip-Verbindung und geht zum Fritz-Phone.
So.
Ähm, dann nennen wir das Ding jetzt hier auch mal Fritz-Phone-Session.
So, gut.
So, Fritz-Phone, Fritz-Phone-Session.
Fritz-Phone-Session.
Gut, so, und jetzt brauchen wir das gleiche noch umgedreht.
Jetzt brauchen wir das gleiche noch umgedreht.
Und zwar für die Voip-Ver...
Na.
Für die Voip-Verbindung hierhin.
Nur, dass es jetzt keine Fritz-Phone-Session...
Übrigens soll ich das vielleicht nicht Fritz-Phones, sondern mal ordentlich benennen.
So.
Gut.
Nur, dass es jetzt keine Fritz-Phone-Session ist, sondern eine Voip-Session.
Also sprich, ja das Voip zu nennen ist doof, weil ich habe es eine Fritz-Phone genannt.
Also hier zum ZIP-Client auf Linux.
Und da brauchen wir jetzt genau das Umgedrehte.
Nämlich das was dort rauskommt, soll ähm...
Die Source, sollen wir als Source verwenden.
Und als Sync, nehmen wir das zum Fritz-Phone.
Also sprich, das drehen wir einfach um, dass das Sound, dass das Sound...
Wir können es Linux, wir nennen es Linux-Phone, ja.
Linux-Phone-Session.
Genau.
Das ist besser.
Und das hier nennen wir auch, das hier nennen wir auch nicht Voip-Session.
Sondern das nennen wir auch...
Linux-Phone...
Fritz-...
Ups.
What the fuck?
Hä?
Wait a minute, warum hat das jetzt nicht funktioniert?
Refactor?
Rename?
Hä?
Ok.
Was, was, was, was auch immer.
Linux-Phone...
To Fritz-Phone.
Genau.
Das ist gut.
So nennen wir das.
Linux-Phone-Session.
Gut.
Linux-Phone-Call.
So, also wir drehen die beiden Sachen um.
Das, was hier der Output ist, kommt hier auf den Input.
Und das, was hier der Output ist, kommt da auf den Input.
Also, sodass wir halt die beiden...
Dass wir Kopfhörer...
Also, dass wir Lautsprecher und Sprache verbinden.
In eine Richtung und Lautsprecher und Sprache mit Mikrofon in die andere Richtung.
Das ist die Scham.
Doch, doch.
So, Linux-Phone-Call.
Vielleicht sollte ich das nochmal richtig nennen.
So, und wenn das jetzt funktioniert,
dann solltet ihr mich hören, wenn ich in das Fritz-Phone reinrede.
Gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
Prediction?
Wollen wir Prediction machen, ob es funktioniert?
Okay.
Prediction.
Äh, Vorhersage starten.
Äh.
Werdet ihr...
Warte mal.
Wird es funktionieren?
Fragezeichen.
Funktionieren?
Ergebnis Ja.
Ergebnis Nein.
30 Sekunden.
Bäm.
Schauen wir mal.
Mit Kanalpunkten.
Ja, wenn schon.
Ja, wenn schon richtig.
Slot-Streams sind nix dagegen.
Habt ihr's grad...
Habt ihr's grad von, weil ich mit nur zwei Leerzeichen einrücke, oder was?
Ja, Tabs sind bloated.
Und vier Leerzeichen sind auch bloated.
Zwei Leerzeichen sind nicht bloated.
Nee, ich mag das eher, weil ich dann weniger Eindrückungstiefe hab.
Weiß ich, mir...
Das ist persönlicher Geschmack.
Ich würde auch vier Tabs, also vier Eindrückungen, vier Leerzeichen verwenden oder Tabs, wenn ich irgendwo mit Leuten zusammenarbeiten müsste, die vier Tabs, vier Leerzeichen verwenden oder so.
Oh, was ist denn jetzt rausgekommen, Predictions?
Hab ich grad geguckt.
Prediction.
Vorhersage.
74% sagen Ja.
Sag mal, habt ihr zu viele Channelpunkte?
145.000 Channelpunkte auf Ja und 52.000 Kekse auf Nein.
Welches Programm das mit dem Lambda ist, das ist ne Terminal.
Also, dann wollen wir das doch mal probieren.
Ergibt das, ergibt das...
Übrigens, ähm, sollte ich irgendeinen Fehler gemacht haben, dass der Call jetzt gar nicht funktioniert, dann werde ich weder Ja noch Nein machen, sondern das erst fixen, weil es geht ja um die Audioübertragung.
Und wenn es so leise ist, dass nur ich mich höre und ihr euch nicht, dann mach ich es erst mal so.
Und wenn es so leise ist, dass nur ich mich höre und ihr euch nicht, dann mach ich es erst mal lauter.
Okay, schauen wir mal, schauen wir mal.
Also, ich führ das jetzt aus, ruf mich an, ich mute mich und dann gucken wir mal, ob wir... Moment.
Ich mach die Musik aus und dann gucken wir mal, ob man mich hört.
So, Registration successful, ich mute mich jetzt.
Hallo?
Oh, es funktioniert.
Ich laber jetzt ins Fritz-Phone.
Und es hört sich scheiße an.
Aber für, ähm, ja, so Audio aus Telefon ist das schon okay, ne?
Nee, Telefonsaunen ist immer kacke.
Da kannst du nichts dagegen machen.
Aber es funktioniert.
Stonks.
Das hat ungefähr so 250 Millisekunden Verzögerung.
Das ist ja auch kein Mikrofon.
Das ist das Fritz-Phone.
Okay, ich leg jetzt auf.
So, jetzt bin ich wieder am Start.
Also.
Predictions.
Mods, könnt ihr das bitte markieren, dass das gepunzt hat?
Also, easy.
Hat alles funktioniert.
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt...
...weiterleiten von einem deckt Telefon-Call.
Ja, das können wir bei der Gelegenheit mal ausbrechen.
Was ist denn ein besserer Audio-Codec als die, die ich hier verwende?
Was haben wir denn sonst noch für Audio-Codecs?
Also, wir verwenden jetzt PCMA.
Was ist ein guter Codec?
G2... Mal gucken, ob es das kann.
G22.
Ja, können wir machen.
Ich kopiere das mal kurz hier rauf.
Es kann jetzt aber auch sein, dass die Verbindung danach nicht mehr funktioniert, weil...
...einer der beiden Quellen das nicht kann.
Schauen wir mal.
Okay.
Das Ding unterstützt die Codecs nicht. Kann das sein?
Was kann der für Codecs?
Audio?
Audio-Codecs.
Okay.
Audio? Audio-Codecs.
G?
Ah, der kann das nicht.
Der kann das nicht.
Aber wir können den vielleicht einfach einmal anschalten.
Okay.
Sag mal, ist das wirklich besser?
Ich meine, das hat auch eine richtig beschissene Abtastrate.
Specs könnte man auch machen.
Specs, ist das nicht das von Teamspeak?
Bitrate.
Was hat PCMU für eine Bitrate?
Auch 80 sollte eigentlich keine so große Ordnung...
Okay, probieren wir das aus. Probieren wir das nochmal aus.
Ich muss mich muten.
Hallo?
Oh, das hört sich viel besser an.
Oder?
Ja, viel besser.
Es war immer noch nicht so gut wie übers Mikrofon, aber viel besser.
Ich meine, ich brauche halt irgendeinen Codec, den beide Seiten unterstützen.
Okay.
Teste mal Opus. Ich glaube, die Fritzbox kann das nicht.
Können wir mal ausprobieren.
Können wir mal ausprobieren, ob das geht.
Oh, das kann der hier gar nicht.
Hat das vielleicht einen anderen Namen?
Ist es irgendetwas anderes hiervon umschrieben irgendwie?
Okay, da müssen wir mal kurz hier danach suchen, ob das Opus, Opus kann.
Opus.
Fritzbox unterstützt das Sprachcodex.
Ah, kann sie nicht. Okay.
Dann müssen wir das auch gar nicht ausprobieren.
Also unterstützte, unterstützte Codex.
Was ist denn da der, warum sind die Dinger so, so, so random benannt?
Alter, G726, kann das das hier?
Wie schaut es mit Presence Detection aus?
Ja, das ist kein Ding. Das könnte ich tatsächlich machen, ja.
Bei zwei ZIP Clients sollte es doch egal sein, was die Fritz kann.
Es sind nicht zwei ZIP Clients.
Es ist immer, an der Stelle immer noch ein Fritzphone, was über die Fritzbox telefoniert.
Es sind nicht ZIP, es ist nicht ZIP zu ZIP.
Es ist Fritz, es ist Fritzphone über Fritzbox zu meinem Programm
und von dort weiter, weiter gebridged zu einer reinen ZIP Verbindung.
ZIP Verbindung. G722 ist HD über Fritzbox.
Ja gut, das haben wir jetzt ja gerade.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch schönes zu bieten?
Oder was ist denn G7, Alter, also mal ganz im Ernst.
Versus G7, also das ist ja wirklich mal wieder eine Wissenschaft für sich.
Was mit G, ah, okay, das reduziert die Bandbreite und das hier erhöht die Qualität.
Was eine bescheuerte Benamung. Warum, was eine ultra bescheuerte Benamung.
Warum nennt man das, warum nennt man die Dinger nicht entweder, keine Ahnung,
Low, High, Medium oder, oder, oder, oder keine Ahnung, Quality und Optimized oder was auch immer.
Warum macht man da random Zahlen hinten dran?
Okay, also bessere Quali wie das, was wir kann hatten, kriegen wir nicht mehr hin.
Was ist, was ist Ilbz? Ilbz, 13,3. Internet Low Bitrate Kodak.
Oh, ich glaube, das, ich glaube, das klingt nicht nach, nach guter Quali.
Nee, ich glaube, besser, ich glaube, besser kriegen wir, kriegen wir das nicht, nicht hin.
Was ist denn G, E, HD versus 722. Nee, ich glaube, bessere Quali kriegen wir nicht hin als das.
Also, ich glaube, wir haben schon, ich glaube, wir haben schon das Beste.
Also, ich meine, man könnte, man könnte natürlich die Verbindung, kann der, kann der es? Nee, kann er gar nicht.
Man könnte halt die reine VoIP-Verbindung besser in Kodak nehmen, aber dann müsste ich re-encoden und re-encoden, das gebe ich mir definitiv nicht.
Na, dann lassen wir es doch auf G777 stehen, da kann man doch, kann man doch wunderbar, wunderbar, wunderbarst exzellent mitleben.
Jo. Was macht der hier damit? Nix.
Nix. Hast du HD Voice in den Deckteinstellungen aktiviert?
Keine Ahnung. Ich kann es mir jetzt auch nicht hier im Stream in der Fritzbox einloggen.
Ich, ich muss es jetzt noch mal kurz ausprobieren.
Wir können uns jetzt aber den Unterschied anhören, ich laber jetzt mal ins Mikrofon vom Headset und in mein Fritz, Fritz Phone.
Hallo? Naja. So ein großer Unterschied ist da nicht, oder? Also, ich muss sagen, großer Unterschied ist da nicht, oder?
Hm. Passt. Ich finde auch, das ist mehr als ausreichend. Kann man sich jetzt nicht beschweren. Bin ich, bin ich okay?
Ah, ah. So. Genau, das ist der Gegensprecher der Lagunkantonsstudio, so sieht es aus. Aber auf der anderen Seite, warum sollte man die Qualität schlechter machen als es ist?
Also, G722, beste. Du willst ja an deiner Klingel keine Konferenzen halten. Wer sagt das denn? Warum nicht?
nicht wenn man erst mal so was hat dann könnte ich auch mit drei weiteren leuten konferenz
machen wenn der dhl mann gerade da steht und der dhl mann kann einfach mitmachen da könnte
ich dann quasi überlegt euch mal was das für möglichkeiten er eröffnet der dhl mann ist an
der klingel und sagt mal wieder er legt es an der tür ab und ich sage er soll mir im fenster
reingeben oder dhl mann sagt nein macht er nicht ich habe so neun dhl mann der macht so komische
komische dinger der alter hat da nie nie probleme gemacht und dann mache ich es einfach so dann
rufe ich schon auf dem zweiten bildschirm die dhl hotline an und dann sagst du warten sie mal
kurz ich schalte mal kurz die hotline dabei und dann habe ich dann mich die dhl hotline und den
dhl mann natürlich gegensprechanlage dran und alle hören sich gegenseitig und die dhl hotline kann
dem dhl mann erst mal erzählen wie das machen muss das ist doch was magst du stimmt dhl frau
natürlich auch aber ich hatte bisher nur dhl menner und in dem konkreten fall ist es im dhl
mann der neuerdings der meinung ist pakete nicht mehr mir ins fenster geben zu wollen
ja das muss ich auf jeden fall ausprobieren wie die quali ist gegensprechanlage und sonst
wieder ich habe es jetzt ja zwischen fritz vorn und anlage getestet also kann ja sogar sein kann
ja sogar sein dass diese dieser analog telefon zu deckt dass der das gar nicht kann wir können
mal gucken ich habe da ich habe da eine das ist eine disti box 300 die bei mir die deckt
also analog telefon zu deckt macht kann die denn für codecs oder was kann deckt was kann
entdeckt für codecs na gut das was die fritz vorn kann codec was war das g722 ja das verraten
sie einem nicht gucken wir mal gucken wir mal ins handbuch f a q manual codec e 7 1 steht
nichts drinne ja dann muss ich das zeigen die sollten doch total egal sein da bin ich
mir nicht so sicher wie das bei deckt mit codecs aussieht das kann ich egal sein weil
dann wäre ja die sprachqualität viel viel besser zwischen deckt unter zwischen dem
handy und der fritz box wenn der codec zwischen fritz box zwischen fritz box und meinen programm
so viel ausmacht also ich denke schon dass das ja das macht einen unterschied jetzt muss das
endgerät können das muss das endgerät können die fritz box wandelt da nichts um die fritz gut
vielleicht wandelt die fritz box das um wenn beide geräte unterschiedlich unterschiedlich codecs
können ja warum sollte deckt ein ip codec verwenden ist doch kein ip codec das ist ein
audiokompressionsverfahren doch noch mal deckt codec g722 deckt derzeit kommt g722
insbesondere auch cut q was das auf dem deckt standard aufbaut siste leute also
das endgerät muss das können das kann auch sein das weiß ich nicht kann auch sein dass wenn
die endgeräte das nicht supporten das nicht geht es könnte aber auch sein dass die wobei nein das
geht nicht weil die fritz box die fritz box in dem fall wahrscheinlich auch nur da wobei also wenn
es komplette wenn es kommt wenn es sieb zu sieb gerät also sieb klein zu sieb klein ist dann ist
es so wenn die sich nicht einig werden dann geht es nicht weil dazwischen ist es ja keine kein proxy
dazwischen ist es ja nur eine registrierungsvermittlung die geräte reden ja direkt miteinander aber in
dem fall geht ja wirklich deckt zur fritz box und die fritz box wandelt macht daraus einen
sieb anruf also das könnte schon sein dass es muss auf jeden fall über die fritz box drüber das
heißt die fritz box könnte theoretisch an der stelle auch die codex umwandeln was aber bescheuert
wäre ach scheiß drauf ich probiere das dann einfach aus und gut ist ja aber an sich funktioniert das
doch schon mal ganz gut muss man sagen ist mir zu viel fritz box ja ich bin auch dafür wir sollten
wir sollten den fritz box anteil bisschen zurückschreiben zurückschrauben und hier
nicht fritz.box reinschreiben sondern 192 168.0.17 das ist viel besser ist soviel soviel soviel
fritz auch genannt die rote pest aus berlin weiß ich wo ich das mal gelesen habe in irgendeinem
forum und nachdem AVM rot ist und aus berlin kommt lernst du den code auf github vielleicht
das ist ja aktuell total random shit die specs können sich nicht ändern bei der fritz box das
hat nämlich mit den fritz box specs nichts zu tun das ist zip und irgendwelche offiziellen codex
da kann sich nichts ändern das ist standard das ist das schöne das ist das ist das schöne das
schöne an standards wie so ein zip telefoncall aufgebaut ist ist standardisiert da kann die da
kann AVM nicht einfach sagen oh ne hab ich jetzt keinen bock drauf lass ich bleiben
übrigens was wir noch machen müssten ist was wir noch machen müssten ist guck mal ich
könnte sagen ja wenn ich mal mein linux call absetze ich könnte jetzt noch sagen wenn wenn
der auflegt dann soll er die andere session also häng ab und call hung ab also wenn ich hier
wenn ich hier auflege dann soll er die verbindung zu meinem fritz phone auch abbauen ok dass das
probieren es mal aus das sollte ja von der idee ganz einfach sein also sprich wenn das hier also
wenn wenn ich hier auflege dann nehme ich einfach die fritz den fritz von call und sag auch hang
ab und gut ist du die klingel auf dein telefon ja das funktioniert folgendermaßen temporäre
aufbau mittlerweile ist es im keller klingel in so ein offizielles interface von siedle das
macht daraus einen analogen telefoncall der analoge telefoncall geht hier an so einen deck analog zu
deck converter und dann von dort an die fritz box also ihr müsst euch mal überlegen was da
einer zwischen ist das ist wenn wenn einer klingelt einer klingelt und mit mir reden will dann geht
es erstmal hier lang rein analog interne siedle protokoll dann wird daraus analoga telefoncall
gemacht geht weiter an deck dann geht es über deck an die fritz box dann geht es dann macht macht
die fritz box dann macht die fritz box einen zipcall draus der zipcall geht ins internet übers
internet über mobilfunk an mein handy und dann wieder zurück dass das überhaupt funktioniert
dass das überhaupt geht das sind so viele fehlerquellen unterwegs mir fehlt der schritt
mit fax und anschließend im ocr ja also gerade wenn man für behörden arbeitet kann ich mir
vorstellen wenn ich in ordentlichen fax gateway baue das wäre da bestimmt der renner nein das
ist kein das ist kein ip gerät das ist kein ip gerät das ist noch ein altes 1 plus n gerät
deswegen funktioniert das übrigens auch so gut wenn es wenn es schon wenn es schon ein
bus gerät wäre wäre das soweit ich es gesehen habe gar nicht so einfach möglich was ich da
jetzt bauen will da gibt es zwar auch adapter die nehmen dann aber komplett leglichen call an und
sonst wie das ist dann schwieriger dem fall habe ich mal ausnahmsweise glück bitte eine fax
benachrichtigung mit bild das klingeln bei nicht ernahme des klingeln calls das wisst ihr ich
weiß es ist eigentlich ein witz aber wo ist eigentlich in dem projekt ffmpeg ffmpeg kommt
für das kamerabild dabei ich weiß nicht ob wir das kamerabild heute hinbekommen weil es
es ist ja so gedacht dass dieser call der jetzt hier aktuell an diesen zip client geht dass ich
den das da noch den kamerabild dazu soll also der nimmt den sound vom fritz phone aber der
bekommt noch eine videosauce dabei der bekommt noch eine videosauce dabei und das ist dann ffm
ffmpeg von der kamera zum testen irgendein aufgezeichnetes video file das kommt in dem
ffmpeg ja aber um jetzt hier noch was zu sagen ich weiß dass das natürlich nicht ernst gemeint ist
aber das coole ist mit sowas sind da keine grenzen gesetzt also nachdem ich mich ja hier
komplett selbst um das handling kümmere so was wie wo angerufen werden soll könnte ich ohne
probleme da jetzt noch einbauen dass er den fax schickt mit dem bild des klingelten und
dass dann aus dem fax gerät rauskommt ist zwar absolut unsinnig aber es würde funktionieren
was du suchst ein altes ffmpeg mit ndi für windows warum brauchst du ein altes ffmpeg
warum kannst du nicht einfach neues ffmpeg nehmen ffmpeg baut doch eigentlich so gut wie nie features
aus weil ndi nicht open source ist das heißt aber es war ja mal drin in ffmpeg die haben das
doch nicht ausgebaut oder doch ach die haben das wirklich rausgenommen ok das ist selten
normalerweise sammelt sich in ffmpeg eigentlich nur 100 jahre audio video zeusch an
ja aber das ist nice dass das funktioniert dass das ist progas das freut mich ich bin
jetzt ich bin jetzt aber überlegen ob wir noch eine halbe stunde weiter progas machen
oder für für bettgetime vorher noch ein bisschen ein bisschen videos gucken ich glaube ich glaube
ich gucke mal kurz in meiner watch later history was ich ob ich da irgendwas interessantes drin
habe wirklich wenn es an li schleiner selbst zerstört deine meinung ja er gibt es noch
irgendwas was ich nicht weiß haben die war noch irgendwas was ich jetzt nicht mitbekommen habe
also ich habe keine aktive selbst zerstörungen mitbekommen ich habe halt mitbekommen dass die
sag mal mal wenig wenig gemacht haben um eben das zu verbreiten also sprich die hatten zum
beispiel also meiner meinung nach was zu dem desinteresse geführt hat ist es gab keine
offiziellen server mit sagen wir mal sinnvoll im rule set sinnvoll moderiert das ist eigentlich
das was du bereitstellen musst ja also ach ja das kenne ich das problem habe ich auch da hatte
ich auch aufgehört memory league du hast du hast zwei runden gespielt und das game ist gecrashed
ja dann hatte ich auch kein bock mehr da habe ich auch ausgemacht aber die hatten die hatten
vorher schon das problem die hatten keine offiziellen server und du kannst nicht du
kannst nicht erwarten dass community server von irgendwelchen random leuten mit mit ganz
komischen rule sets und dingern die leute da langfristig begeistern du hättest zwei
offizielle server machen müssen und conquest server und rush server und auf beiden hättest
du mods laufen lassen müssen die das spiel sinnvoll erweitern aber nicht ein ganz anderes
game draus machen zum beispiel hätte man hätte man den mod drauf machen können dass es soll mit
engineer waffen spielen kann und so was ja das ist ein sinnvoller mod den fand ich richtig cool
dass da konntest du grad mal auch waffen spielen die du kaum gespielt hast im original solche
solche dinger ja auch die auch ihre ihre paar map rework diese hatten wo sie dann die beleuchtung
teilweise anders gemacht was wunderbar aber halt nicht ein komplett anderes game draus machen und
dann dazu weil das halt komplett keine cheat pro anti cheat oder sonst was hatte und dazu halt
einen server mit admins die für diesen job auch geeignet sind nicht leute die im prinzip alle
aus ihrer freunde bannen oder permanent selbst am rumflamen sind oder selbst am cheaten sind
sondern wirklich den admin team aus keine ahnung fünf bis zehn leuten die das die das die das
ernst nehmen und das haben wir seriös machen und dann das was du sagst genau dass man auch
durchaus so dinger macht wie den ranking oder so nach dem motto an die meisten headshots oder
aber auch offiziell wer hat die beste kd oder keine ahnung dass man sich ein paar stats angucken
kann ja leider leider ja das ist halt das hat lächerlich sowas jetzt wo ich der name
liest hattest du nicht hattest du nicht in den service wo man wo man server mieten kann
haben wir nicht sogar mal bei dir auf dem auf dem server mal gespielt oder bringe ich das jetzt
durcheinander was war die frage hier what hat leider eigentlich den gui editor für
sie schaap schaap ist eine programmiersprache die das schreibt man in oder meinst du für
windows forms für windows für altes windows forms hat es hat es einen gui editor aber
für für dort nett kann es das glaube ich noch nicht dann musst du visual studio verwenden
guck wenn du es in visual studio aufmachst dann hast du für windows forms den gui editor ach nee
ach du hast der cloudflare also hier kannst du windows forms gui zusammenziehen wobei man
halt sagen muss dass ganz ehrlich gui unter windows ist einfach so extrem pains jam weil
microsoft nicht auf nicht geschissen bekommt windows forms ist noch ist mal ohne scheiß
windows forms ist noch das beste leider hoffnungslos veraltet das siehst du allein
schon daran ich zeige euch jetzt mal warum windows forms veraltet keine farbigen emojis
und alles was keine farbigen emojis kann im jahr 2021 ist old as fuck wpf ist ein bisschen
neuer hat aber richtig cringe richtig cringe richtig cringe wenn das nicht geht wpf ist
ein bisschen neuer hat aber auch probleme dafür ist wpf für den einstieg komplett kompliziert
uwp müssen wir gar nicht von reden kannst du eh nicht verwenden und die chance die sie hatten
mit winui 3 endlich mal zu sagen wir unterstützen ganz normale unpackaged wie sieht es denn da
eigentlich aus wie sieht es da eigentlich aus auf github gucken unpackaged windows applications
zu erstellen haben sie verschenkt winui 3 wäre das beste gewesen was microsoft hätte machen
können ich weiß nicht in welcher parallel welt microsoft lebt die leute wollen kein uwp machen
und die leute können oftmals auch anwendungstechnisch gar kein uwp machen die leute wollen auch
heutzutage ehrlich gesagt kein windows forms oder uwp oder oder wpf machen sie sind aber
dazu gezwungen weil es nichts anderes gibt gescheites also von microsoft für windows integriert
gibt gibt schon möglichkeiten ja und die nui machen soll für unpackaged apps was meint
ihr warum elektron und solche sachen so verbreitet sind als desktop anwendung klar einmal weil
cross platform aber auch weil es microsoft jahrelang verschissen hat mit gui technologien
unter windows ist ist einfach so uwp macht keiner dabei verstand ist und jetzt hätten
sie sagen können mit winui 3 wir nehmen die uwp gui technik die ja an sich durchaus in
ordnung ist mein du kannst so coole sachen machen wie ich sage jetzt nicht den taschenrechner
sondern der hintergrund vom taschenrechner guckt euch mal an der hintergrund vom taschenrechner
der ist nicht einfach nur transparent wie man denken würde der hintergrund vom taschenrechner
ist so transparent dass man immer noch sieht vom kontrast her alles auf den alles auf den
buttons also sprich der kontrast ändert sich nicht nur den hintergrund der reingeblendet
wird die gucken auch dass der kontrast gut lesbar ist also die haben da schon ein paar
coole sachen dabei und die hätten die chance gehabt mit winui 3 die uwp gui technologie
für ganz normale ganz normale unpackaged apps für unpackaged programme bereitzustellen
das wäre das gewesen was sie hätte machen müssen package programme bedeutet im endeffekt
du kannst du über den app store vertreiben gut nicht nur aber hauptsächlich dafür was
man gedacht aber du brauchst einen code signing zertifikat code signing zertifikat kostet
sich keine 200 euro im jahr das holt sich ein normaler hobby entwickler nicht ja ich
gebe zu ich gebe zu dass eben ist jetzt auch gerade richtig high level high IQ talk gewesen
wer sich nicht mit winnows mit winnows entwicklung auseinandergesetzt habe ich glaube den meisten
jetzt nichts gesagt haben aber das muss muss jetzt einfach mal los werden nee das ging
nicht mit der aero mit der aero ging transparent aber diese logik dass du die bedienelemente
anpasst dem hintergrund entsprechend so dass der kontrast immer gewährleistet ist das
ist gut guck mal zum beispiel nehmen jetzt mal hintergrund und machen den komplett schwarz
darf man es überhaupt heute noch sagen so hintergrund komplett schwarz und du siehst
obwohl der hintergrund komplett schwarz ist check der das wo er das macht mit dem kontrast
von den von den von den buttons und dem text drauf ja das heißt es ist keine einfache
transparent sondern das ist transparent mit logik dabei so und das ist tatsächlich neu
das gab es in aero noch nicht acrylic heißt das ja ich glaube heißt wirklich so nein das
ist nicht normaler blöder der mag den hintergrund zwar blören aber dadurch dass du die wenn
das normaler blöder wäre ich zeige das noch mal so guck mal hier ändert sich die hintergrund
farbe von den von den bedienelementen sogar sogar von denen hier sogar von denen hier
ihr seht hier ändert sich die hintergrundfarbe von den bedienelementen aber hier ändert
die sich auch aber die hört auf ab einem gewissen wert weil sie sonst wissen oder weil sie
sich festgestellt haben wenn ich das noch weiter mache dann ist der kontrast nicht mehr hoch
genug zwischen den schwarzen buttons und dem schwarzen hintergrund also es ist es ist nicht
einfach nur blöder ist nicht einfach nur transparent da ist ein bisschen logik dahinter
ich will nicht sagen dass es jetzt die biggest brain logik auf dieser welt ist ich meine
es immer noch microsoft aber es ist nicht einfach nur transparenz so und diese technologie
hätten sie die chance gehabt mit video 3 endlich mal so daraus zu bringen dass man die als
normaler entwickler verwenden kann hatten sie aber kein bock drauf wir gucken mal gerade
was microsoft dazu sagt unpackaged ja support in unpackaged was sagt microsoft dazu
was haus den controls was geht das geht das mittlerweile jetzt pre-release schon die das
ist mit alter das ist mir zu big brain was die hier wollen was ist das ja genau das war
die eigentliche diskussion dass das nicht funktioniert win forms läuft unter allem dotnet core based
mittlerweile anscheinend haben die immer noch probleme ja natürlich ist also hat er recht
du brauchst unpackaged apps wer will dann diesen ganzen kack mit microsoft zone code
signing zertifikat machen hermes bg dankeschön für den sub ja korrekt du kannst doch nicht
von den leuten die das verwenden erwarten wollen ein extra zertifikat installieren
die computer developer modus setzen der microsoft die sind so weltfremd teilweise ich will keine
sign packages haben ich will stink normale zeug programmieren und zum download anbieten
auf sagen wir auf github oder so ich weiß nicht in welchem parallel universum microsoft
bei gui geschichten lebt da sieht man ja auch daran dass ihr eigenes gui scheiße ist und
dass alle anderen anbieter mittlerweile wenn sie wenn sie wenn sie nicht nur alt code
base haben alles mit elektron machen mittlerweile oder cute ja origin ist origin ist also ea
origin ist im prinzip eigentlich nur einen verpackter chrome also so eine art elektron
mit cute overlay steam auch ob ich da das overlay nicht weiß wie die das machen nvidia
geschiss hier ist auch elektron glaube discord ist klar discord discord ist auch elektron
mit ein bisschen custom c++ modulen ja es ist einfach es ist einfach leider mittlerweile
so dass weil microsoft das gui technisch 15 jahre verschissen hat die leute mittlerweile
einfach lieber 40 browser parallele aufnahmen auf ihrem desktop und deswegen 32 gigabyte
ram brauchen weil microsoft nicht schafft ordentliches gui geschichte rauszubringen
ja es gibt noch ein paar alternativen avalonia aber das wird nie in den zustand kommen mal
ganz ehrlich das wird nie in den 3 mann projekt oder sowas das wird nie in den zustand kommen
die sachen zu supporten die die mann eigentlich sagen wir so out of the box bräuchte ja du
brauchst zum beispiel einen richtig guten webview du brauchst ich weiß dass es da umwege für
gibt ja du brauchst die möglichkeit direkt 3d 2d content rein zu rendern und solche geschichten
also dass du doch alle alle du kannst mit avalonia bestimmt 95 prozent der anwendung
umsetzen die du brauchst aber halt die letzten 5 5 prozent machen es dann halt aus cute ist
nach wie vor das beste also qt ist nach wie vor das beste cross platform gui framework
von desktop leider c++ ich weiß es gibt ein paar peissen beinig aber bei manchen sachen
musst du immer noch auf c++ zurückgreifen und ansonsten ich setze auf flatter ganz
ehrlich ich tippe drauf wenn flatter endlich mal richtig gas gibt auf dem desktop wo sie
ja schon grundsteine für gelegt haben dann wird auch flatter auf dem desktop erfolgreich
sein und flatter wird neben elektron dann das zweit meist benutzte cross platform framework
werden wir reden jetzt hier nicht von mobil sondern wir reden von desktop also windows
mac linux und eventuell dazu noch android ios gibt es wirklich leute die so was schreiben
c++ herzchen und das auch so meinen es gibt ja nichts also doch aber wenig was ich mehr
hasse als c++ frag mich nicht nach das blut das ist fluent ne ach nee doch fluent ist das
im hintergrund ist glaube ich acrylic mit diesen farben und das alles dieses ganze design geschiss
hier heißt bei microsoft dann glaube ich flat ui aber da blick ich nicht durch bei microsoft
was ist das trending c++ repo auf github ok das ist eine gute idee das gucken wir jetzt
das gucken wir jetzt trending c++ repositories today ein download manager wo ich mich auch
wieder frage warum um alles in der welt ist ein download manager in c++ programmiert wollen
die quälen die leute sich gerne oder was also wollen die sich sind so masochisten die sagen
so nach dem motto ja besten hier ich ich nehme ich das mal ich peitsche ich peitsche mich
auch jedes mal bevor ich den editor aufmache alter ich geisel mich erstmal eine runde hier
bäm vorher kann ich nicht programmieren und danach mache ich noch weiter nämlich 10 plus
plus programmieren oder wie darf man sich das vorstellen warum macht man das in c++
übrigens hier falls ich jetzt zwar weiß ich was gesagt wenn du c++ machen gern c++ programmieren
kannst du machen ich habe damit keine schmerzen ich bekomme nur anfälle ich finde c++ mittlerweile
noch so ein halb und den jungen leuten ja moment moment moment c++ c++ ist was aus dem trend
c++ ist die sprache die die ganzen competitive programmer und die ganzen gut bei den ctf
leuten weiß ich nicht aber zum größten teil denke ich da auch was die ganzen ctf leute
und die ganzen challenge leute competitive programming pyson können auch viel ctf sein
ja verwenden aber zumindest die ganzen competitive programmers die verwenden c++ aber jetzt
auch nicht weil die c++ mega krass geil finden sondern weil oftmals ausführungszeit eine
rolle spielt und weil die standard library wohl für das also genau für diesen anwendungszweck
gut passt also sprich c++ ist schnell wenn es kombiniert ist und das ist wichtig für
diese ganzen für diesen ganzen competitive programming challenges du kriegst ja einmal
geld nicht geld punkte irgendwie wie schnell du die aufgabe löst und wie schnell dein
programm am ende ist das ist schnell und die standard library ist wohl der beste kompromiss
aus speed plus umfang deswegen verwenden die c++ ansonsten und und warum die c++ auch noch
verwenden was dazu kommt du kannst halt ganz abartige dinger zusammen hacken in c++ wenn
du es wenn du weißt was du machst du kannst ja diese du kannst ja die meisten sachen auch
nicht lesen so wirklich was dabei die kompeten was aber diesen competitive challenges eingecheckt
wird die man die schreiben keine variablen die länger sind als ein buchstabe jeder stimmt
nicht ich habe auch genug beispiele gesehen da nennen sie es doch ein bisschen länger
aber sagen wir so länger als ein wort ist da seltene variablen also diese nische dafür
ist das wohl wirklich gut aber ansonsten ich ich hasse c++ einfach so ein rotz alter
ich hatte letzt ich hatte gestern wieder irgendwas ich habe ein bisschen sp 32 gebastelt
ich hatte gestern wieder irgendwas wo ich mich gefragt habe was zum fack c++ ich weiß
es jetzt aber aus dem kopf nehmen was waren das hatte ich denn wie gesagt hab gestern
oder vorgestern irgendwie ein bisschen sp 32 gebastelt da gab es wieder eine sache da
habe ich gesagt meine fresse warum ist das in c++ so scheiße und es war nicht operator
overloading das ist auch scheiße wenn es wiesen c++ gemacht ist ich komme jetzt nicht drauf
habe das extra in mein c++ sackdokument reinkopiert weil ich mir das merken wollte habe ich aber
nicht gesüngt klar hat sich c++ verbessert ich weiß nicht mehr in welcher sprache ist
c++ programmiert die frage ist falsch gestellt du musst dich fragen in welcher sprache ist
der compiler programmiert den du verwendest um dann c++ zu übersetzen und da ist die antwort
höchstwahrscheinlich ist es entweder gcc oder oder lvm also das ist wahrscheinlich bei
lvm wie heißt der kram lvm ja genau da ist es t++ und gcc ist glaube ich in tnc aber
das muss nicht so sein das muss nicht so sein also du kannst ohne probleme auch einen compiler
für eine sprache basteln der nicht in dieser sprache selbst programmiert ist das das das
geht ist eigentlich gar kein problem warum soll es nicht gehen compiler muss muss aus
der syntax der sprache ja letztendlich irgendwelche binary sachen erzeugen und mit welcher sprache
er das selbst macht ist erstmal unerheblich schmacks dankeschön für den sub nein muss
ich zum glück nicht auf der arbeit sind es meistens irgendwelche tools oder irgendwelche
cli geschichten oder irgendwelche background services oder ich mache einen webgui obendrauf
aber desktop desktop applications habe ich glaube ich in meiner ganzen zeit wo ich jetzt
dort bin nicht eine erstellt ne ja gut ich habe auch kein bock für windows was zu bauen
wie gesagt ich denke es sollte jeder das verwenden was er will.
heute nur just chatting wir haben die sache für heute schon ok ok nur mal als beweis dass
wir heute auch was sinnvolles gemacht haben also bam so mein code meldet sich bei meiner
fritzbox an ich nehme meinen fritzbox phone rufe mich an der call geht durch es klingelt
in meinem zip client auf linux ich nehme an mute mich und rede jetzt über meinen fritzbox
mit euch also das ist der beweis dass es funktioniert was wir heute gemacht haben und das nächste
mal kommt dann das kamerabild noch dabei also nur mal so als beweis dass wir heute auch
wirklich was gemacht haben ich suche nicht k also eins habe ich schon gelernt ich werde
definitiv nie im stream nach sachen suchen die der chain law in chat schreibt pap ich
habe kein problem mit pap ich mache zwar nichts in pap aber ich muss sagen pap ist durchaus
mittlerweile kann man benutzen
ne das war auf aliexpress wo wir nach huge usb gesucht haben und wir haben irgendwelche
viperators gefunden ok was sind denn die trending c++ repositoris ja lass noch mal gucken ok
in den download manager game engine ok das ist ein punkt da da verstehe ich irgendwo
warum es in c++ programmiert ist auch wenn es mich abfacken würde und ich definitiv
wenn ich die auswahl hätte also wahrgenommen ich möchte ein spiel machen ich hätte die
auswahl zwischen verschiedenen engines und eine benutzt die scharp und das ist unity
und eine benutzt c++ das ist unreal und ein paar andere ich weiß sofort was ich nehmen
würde ich instant oder ich würde mit monogame irgendwelche 2d geschichten machen wahrscheinlich
aber nicht aber nicht desto trotz also ich würde im leben keine engine nehmen wo ich
c++ programmieren muss ich mein klar man kann unreal auch rein mit wie heißt das bei unreal
blueprints programmieren aber ich gehe mal davon aus früher oder später wirst du allein
schon effizienz wegen also ich meine damit nicht die die ich meine die programmiere effizienz
also du wirst wahrscheinlich logik viel sinnvoller wenn es ein bisschen was kompliziertes ist
in irgendeinem c++ oder was auch immer scriptsprache da unreal hat basteln als 100 seiten blueprints
machen ja das unity hinter den c++ es mag sein aber du kannst deine gesamte spiel logik
ich glaube du brauchst für unity selbst wenn du irgendwelche irgendwelche extensions und
sachen machen muss eigentlich nix c++ programmieren braucht man c++ bei unity in irgendeiner art
und weise warum keine java script game engine gibt es sicherlich auch so was ist was trennt
sonst noch irgendwelches data ja gut das muss halt schnell sein click aus open pilot das
kenne ich das ist irgendein proxy genau grpc ok ok dass man gut die b in c++ ist wusste
ich gar nicht dachte dass immerhin dass es in c programmiert ist aber wenn die wollen
dann sollen sie machen deluxe zwei monate dankeschön für den sub wann macht man ein
native das wird mich jetzt echt mal interessieren ab wann ist der punkt gekommen in unity wo
man ein native plugin machen würde kann das sein wenn man beispielsweise ok ok ich rate
jetzt mal mal angenommen es gebe was weiß ich unter linux sagen wir mal irgendwie einen
neuen display manager den ich unterstützen will was schwachsinnig ist für den game aber
ja also so irgendwelche basic sachen die nicht so einfach rein mit logik irgendwelche bindings
zu neuen sachen die nicht so einfach mit logik abgefackelt werden können mit mit c sharp logik
abgefackelt werden können also wir haben hier fällt jetzt kein gescheites beispiel beispiel
ein anti cheat system das anti cheat system ist so eine mischung aus server und klein
geschichte ich glaube nicht dass du für ein anti cheat system da in unity c++ was machen
muss treiber anti cheat ok ja siehste keine ahnung höre ich mich in irgendeiner art und
weiße so an als wüsste ich wie das mit unity funktioniert ich rate nur das weiß ich wie
das wie das wie das ist paper gs das heißt was er immer paper gs die seite heißt nicht
so paper gs. org natürlich was auch high performance high performance big brain javascript showcase
proppen geht nicht super ah ok video playback ah verstehe verstehe ok ja ok also sagen wir
zum beispiel sagen wir zum beispiel zum beispiel ich ich ich programmiere ein game wo ich auf
irgendeiner wand ein video abspielen will oder sowas dann nehme ich dann ffm pack fürs
video decoden und dann muss ich irgendwie gucken wie ich wie ich da meine einzelnen
decoden video frames in meinem spiel auf die wand kriege oder so ok ja nintendo halt
naja gut ein ordentliches anti cheat oder generell security funktioniert ja oder sollte
in der regel ja nicht darüber funktionieren dass man weiß wie es funktioniert und das
deswegen ausgehebelt ist sondern wenn was ordentlich sicher implementiert ist solltest
du wissen können wie es funktioniert ohne dass du was dagegen machen kannst gut ich gebe
zu das ist ist bei anti cheat natürlich ein bisschen schwierig oftmals oftmals passiert
da vieles auf obfuscaten dass du nicht genau weißt wo du gucken muss wo was hingeht wo
was nachgeguckt wird und so gerade wenn du bei anti cheat weißt was gecheckt wird um zu
gucken ob irgendwas läuft und wenn ich das weiß und dann mache ich halt gerade woanders
hin dann ist natürlich klar das ist doof ja also was weiß ich wenn immer was weiß ich
ich gucke an dieser adresse ob irgendwas da ist ich gucke ob diese usb geräte angeschlossen
sind blablabla wenn ich diese liste natürlich raus bekomme und weiß das ist doof wenn ich
sowas die kompilen kann ja
ja ich copy ich copy paste gerne eins
oh ich gucke gerade ich sehe es gerade auf der uhr leute wisst ihr was jetzt ist
was was ist jetzt schon spät ist genau was was ist jetzt
korrekt ich sehe ich sehe der chat weiß schon bescheid
geteim der frasier ist on warum ist ja der frasier on
der fabian ist on seit dreieinhalb stunden mit irgendwelchen komischen mobile games wieder
alles klar
ok alles klar leute wir sehen uns bis denn machts gut co